want to be happy build a life not just a
business hey it's evan carmichael and
this channel was created to help you
overcome the number one challenge that
is holding you back
a lack of belief in yourself you watch
these videos because you know there's
something more inside you too
you have michael jordan level genius at
something so today let's live your best
believe life and get some incredible
motivation from the one and only
jocko willing
the chronic excuse maker
how do you stop making excuses
this is actually pretty simple and i
said it the other day and you have to
realize you have to
know you have to accept
that all your excuses are lies
[Music]
their lies all of them
think about the things that you tell
yourself the lies
you use to rationalize taking the easy
road
taking the easy road and leaving
discipline behind
think about them
you don't have time that's a lie
you don't have support
that's a lie you don't have
the equipment or the gear
lies you don't you don't know the best
way
who cares that's a lie or you're
too old or you're too young of course
you're too old or too young why
and there's you're too busy
sure you are
that's a lie and
you're too tired or you're too sore
or you're just plain not feeling it lies
lies lies and the list goes
on and on and on
and it doesn't stop if you don't make it
stop
so recognize
recognize the excuses are
not valid they aren't
they're trumped up they're conjured up
they're fabricated they're lies and how
do you stop the lies you stop the lies
with the truth
the truth the truth will set you free
the truth will stand and the truth will
deliver you from procrastination
and laziness and the downward spiral
that comes
with a lack of discipline so
don't believe the lies believe the truth
and the truth is
you have time you have the skill you
have
the knowledge and the support and the
willpower
and the discipline to get it done
so cast out the lies
burn them down
and listen to the truth and live the
truth
and go out and get it done
i don't really like those words
self-help or self-management or
self-improvement
i don't really like what those words
have come to mean these days
because there's a lot of people out
there that are constantly trying to
improve
themselves by looking for the one change
the one change right the one change in
their life that's gonna
make their dreams come true
and even worse on top of that there's a
lot of people out there a lot of
self-help gurus and these hyperactive
motivational speakers and
these other self-appointed modern zen
yoga warriors that
they're trying to sell the one thing
they're trying to sell
the nine steps or the enlightened path
that's going to allow you to
unlock all of your human potential and
fulfill the dreams
so you can live the life that you've
you've always wanted to live
now i'm no guru
and i definitely don't claim to be i'm
just a man
but i will tell you this it isn't one
thing
and it isn't ten things and it isn't a
hundred things
it isn't a quick path and there are no
shortcuts and meditation
won't get you there and neither will a
miracle drug or an
organic supplement or some superfood
getting better isn't a hack or a trick
or a one change that you need to make
getting better is a campaign it's a
campaign it's a
daily a weekly it's an hourly fight
an incessant fight that doesn't stop
against
weakness and against temptation and
against laziness it's a campaign of
discipline
the campaign of hard work and dedication
it's waking up early
and going to bed late and grinding out
every second in between
every single day
so you want to get better
you want to self improve stop
looking for a shortcut and go find your
alarm clock
and find your discipline and
find your guts and your passion and your
drive
and find your will
and then and then
you will find your freedom
when things go wrong they
always seem to happen at once and they
just
compound on top of each other
and it's it's pretty easy
sometimes to to feel beaten
when you're faced with all those issues
and all those problems and they all hit
you
at the same time but
let me tell you that that doesn't mean
give up in fact
it means the opposite
it means it's time for you to fight
harder
to dig in means it's time for you to go
on the war
path and that starts with one of the
fundamental laws of combat leadership
prioritize and execute
what's the biggest problem what's
causing the most stress
family okay sit them down
explain where you are at be blunt
be upfront and then give them
the simple plan of how you're gonna get
things back on track
don't sugarcoat it
you give it to them straight next you
got some
some late payments call those creditors
up
explain to them what's going on set up
some kind of a
of a minimum payment plan so you can
start making some progress
and get them off your back and then you
got
your job right you're falling behind at
work
okay talk to your boss face it
[Music]
tell him that you're gonna step up your
game tell him
you're gonna be at work early you're
going to be at work late you're going to
be at work during lunch
you're going to be wherever you need to
be whenever
he needs you to be there
tell him you're going to get after it
and tell him that you're
100 committed
to supporting him and the company
and the mission
and then you get started also if you
want to build more confidence the sign
says it can take up to 254 days
of consecutive action to successfully
build
a habit so i've created a free program
for you where every day
for 254 days i will send you an unlisted
video to your email
absolutely free to help you build your
confidence the link to join is in the
description
below people want to know how to stop
the laziness and they want to know how
to stop
the procrastination and i looked at him
and i said i'm not a brand
i'm a person you have to stop
rationalizing
stop making excuses stop telling
yourself little watered down assessments
of where you're really at tell yourself
the truth
i keep getting asked this type of
question how do i get disciplined or how
do i want discipline or
how do i maintain discipline and the
answer
it's it's a simple answer but obviously
it's not easy and there's all kinds of
little
tricks and methods that people talk
about
and you know they have some merit
you know maybe they do work these these
things you know do the little things
people say and wake up early i say that
and write things down
and take cold showers and
tell everyone what you're going to do so
broadcast it
and make promises or or make bets
with with your friends of something that
you don't want to lose
and those things those ideas they're
cool i'm sure they're going to have
some impact and if they work for you
that's that's awesome
but but the fact of the matter is that
the reason
discipline is hard to maintain is
because it is hard to maintain
that's what makes discipline hard it's
hard
and if you hear me
claim that discipline is easy for me
then straight up that's just my ego
talking
that's what that is because
i'm unfortunately
just as human as everyone else and it is
work
to maintain the discipline that's what
it is work
holding the line maintaining
the standard giving
no slack none that's the discipline
that's the discipline and it is hard
and if there's one thing i would say
that does
make it easier it's to
envision what it feels like when you're
done
what it feels like
after you've worked out or you've held
the line on your food intake or you've
pushed through some monotonous
project that you have to do and all
those things
when they're done they feel good
and contrary to that
envision what you will feel like later
when you let the discipline slack
you know the feeling
feeling weak and defeated
and you know that you're falling behind
so get to know those two different
types of feelings and ask yourself which
one you want to feel in 10 minutes
or in a half an hour
when when the thing is done when
the discipline has been implemented
remember what that feels like and then
remember that those
minutes and those hours they turn into
weeks
and months and years and holding the
line
in those critical minutes will put you
in an infinitely better place physically
and mentally if you maintain
the discipline i've been somewhat of a
pushover for the majority of my life
since listening to the podcast i've been
trying to assert myself more
one thing i can't seem to shake is
constantly being interrupted
how can i rise above and overcome this
obstacle
i want to talk and they all want to talk
over each other and they want to cut
each other off
you get in that group right there i i
don't
talk i don't talk i let their i sit
there i listen to them
and i plot and i think and i put
together my thoughts correctly so that
when i do decide to say something it's
going to have
impact and then i wait for the right
moment
right because if there's people that are
bickering back and forth
i wait for a lull in the fire
and when that lull comes then i
make my point in a very direct manner
i might even i might even have to wait
until the conversation is like all but
over
wait till they're done with their little
fire fight
when i talk you know i'm going to do it
since i've been thinking about it's
going to be
articulated in a way that i can present
my full
point and so i think that's an effective
way to do things i think
i think if you let people speak a bunch
you let them
get it out of their system and then when
you decide to talk they don't have
anything left to say so that's a way to
stop getting cut off so this is almost
like flanking right this is flanking
the fact that when people have a bunch
to say and they got all these
thoughts in their head and they want to
get them all out let them get them out
don't try and fight that battle
they've got a bunch of things they want
to say let them say it also as we
know when you listen to someone else
talk
it you you now know what their ideas are
yeah
you know what they're thinking there's a
power in not saying anything because
it allows you to think and it allows you
to hear what other people think and it
allows you to hear
other people so in a conversation you
get to hear other people's counters to
what people are saying
and you're not you're not having to
expend any ammunition yourself
someone else is doing it you know the
third or fourth or fifth piece person
the conversation that's
expending ammunition and running their
mouth to try and
counter some point that someone's made
let them do that because by the way then
you get to see what the other counter is
so i think being assertive
doesn't mean talking more i think being
assertive
means talking less talking at the
appropriate times
monitoring and understanding the fire
fight that's happening
so that when other people have expended
their ammunition
you can step in and you can take your
shots
in a simple clear concise manner it's
like the little boy that cried wolf
right
if i if i talk and talk and talk and
talk and talk
i'm taking away the value of each one of
those
statements that i make because i'm
making so many statements that not all
of them can have
a high level of value so
who do you who do you pay more attention
to
the person that makes 100 statements
yeah and what are those okay let's say
you want to pay attention the person
that makes 100 statements
how much can you pay attention to those
hundred statements how much do you
how much do you gather from those
hundred statements yeah it's it's a
limited amount
it's one percent per statement right
it's one percent you have to
well do you think i make 100 statements
that's one percent per statement
if the person says one thing how much
percent do you pay attention to that
that's right when
we deployed to iraq in 2006 we'd been
fighting since 2003 and we'd had
very few casualties in the seal teams
the amount of guys that
had experienced their teammates killed
in action was
minuscule and so there was no
preparation other than
what i had taken away from reading about
combat for my whole life
what i did was what i knew how to do
which was work and
that's literally what i told my guys was
we've
we've crossed a line and there's no
there's no possible way to
replace or describe or overcome
the amount of just
heart-wrenching sadness that you feel
when you lose a teammate i didn't know
what to do
and i didn't know what to say i think
that understanding history
and reading and knowing
how people have gone through this before
just the fact
that you know when we we we had a small
number of casualties you know
we lost three guys from tasking a
bruiser
each one of them is an epic loss to us
and to humanity and at the same time in
world war ii in world war one there
would be days where
thousands upon thousands were killed
and so that offered me a small bit of
perspective
to think to myself that human beings we
can feel like we're special
and we can feel like no one's ever been
through what i've been through
and the world is hard for me and easier
for everyone else
well the reality is that's not true and
we're not special
and the things that people go through
other people have
gone through most likely much much worse
and much more significant so that
to me was a it gave me at least some
level of perspective
to realize that other warriors had gone
through this before
this was my turn and this is how i'm
gonna try and handle it
i'm kind of i'm kind of anti-social
right like if you don't know me
we're not going to have a conversation
you know like we're not having
like it's not i'm not i'm not walking up
and talking to you
if i don't know you i'm not walking up
and saying hi to you it's not happening
it's not my personality
if you say hi to me i'll say hi i'm not
disrespectful i'm not rude
but i'm not looking to have a bunch of
conversations with people
and so that's known to me
but that's not okay for the business
side
of my life which is hey i gotta talk to
people gotta build relationships
gotta had to know my commanding officer
had to know the commodore had to know
the the the conventional battalion
commander had to know the brigade
commander had to
build relationships could i just talk
about
the war with the brigade commander
well i could but what's more powerful
that i talk about war and i talk about
where i'm from or where he's from or
what you know
other things yes because i want to build
a relationship why because
i'm trying to build trust what why
because i wanted to allow me to go out
there and
do things in his battle space so that's
what they're asking you they're asking
you to step
out of your comfort zone it doesn't need
to become your primary focus no
should you try and step out of the
comfort zone if you want to grow
if you want to have more opportunity i
would give it a try
i would give it a try if not you know
like i said
if you hate it and you feel like you're
not being true to your true
self that's okay maybe your true self is
meant to be the one that's back
not getting promoted yeah they need
somebody to do that
if it's not you it might be somebody
else yeah
it's another one of those tough
questions where people you know hit me
with like should i just be
should i be loyal to myself because the
the obvious
like answer that everyone wants to hear
is like yeah dude the most important
thing you got to be loyal to yourself
that's the most important thing
yeah okay if that's what your priority
is then that's the most important thing
but guess what who does a who can take
care of the other kitchen dogs that
respect you so much
who can take a better care of them than
you can because if you get promoted
if you don't get promoted and and johnny
glamour boy
gets promoted because he likes to go out
and schmooze the clients
and now he gets promoted and you're and
now who's going to take care of the
kitchen dogs on his
on his time right not him he doesn't
care
he's got he got promoted not for taking
care of his guys he got promoted because
he schmoozed the clients
sometimes even if you're the most highly
motivated person in the world that grind
starts to beat you down a little bit
and that's when you have to stop looking
at the short term thing because that's
not that's not getting you
to get it done and you've got to look
okay what is the long term goal that i'm
looking at
what am i really trying to get done in
the long term and you say oh you know
what
i'm actually waking up today early so i
can be ahead of the curve so i can
sell more of these widgets or whatever
so that i can buy a house
and you know what today matters today
matters this decision that i'm making
right now
is that first step it's me taking one
stroke swimming in the right direction
heading towards the shore and if i don't
take this i'm not making any progress
let's say you're the most ultra
motivated guy in the world when that
alarm clock goes off
there's at least 50 of the time where
you just that that
soft little pillow is just caressing
your head and you want to stay there
and it takes discipline to go nope i'm
going to get up out of this bed i'm
going to do what i'm supposed to do
and that discipline that you have at
that moment you win that fight
that's a big victory and then that that
that pattern will carry out throughout
the day because once you're up well now
that i'm up i might as well go work out
because i'm already up and i
i feel good that i got up out of bed and
i won that battle let me go win another
battle i'm gonna go get it done
and then when you show up at the office
and there's someone that's got a big box
of donuts
that they're giving away for free by the
way so they're just sitting there it's
almost like an insult not to take them
but when you've already gotten up early
you had the discipline there you already
worked out you had the discipline there
and now you see the box of donuts you're
like no i'm not going to eat the donuts
no no donuts you're not going to do it
and that discipline carries on
throughout the day so now you take that
and you you expand that out over a week
in a month
and you end up with more discipline and
it starts with that simple uh act
we all want freedom right we all want to
have freedom we want we don't have
financial
freedom we won't have more free time we
don't have physical freedom that's what
we want everyone wants freedom of course
but if you want to have freedom in your
life the way to get to freedom
is is through discipline it's that's how
you get there so if you want to be if
you want to be
financially free you have to have
financial discipline
you have to save your money you have to
work hard to earn more money you have to
not buy
buy stupid things that you don't
actually need right
you need to save that money and invest
it properly all that takes discipline
and if you have that kind of discipline
you'll end up with more freedom if you
want to be if you want to have more free
time
everybody wants more free time but if
you want more free time how are you
going to get it
you have to have more disciplined time
management i'm a chef
in a large operation kitchen recently
during my last review i was given some
advice by my boss
and his boss should i heed their advice
or stick to
what i do best and keep getting after it
on my terms it's one of those questions
that's just funny how how that last
statement is framed
right yeah should i stick to what i do
best and keep getting after it
as if to say if you say no you should
not stick to what you do best
yes and you should not get after it
right that's that's the frame
there and actually this guy i i answered
the question
real tersely i think this came through
facebook messages you know i said
uh sounds like you found a comfortable
zone for yourself and you want to stay
in there
right little cold-blooded response and
he's like i knew it
uh because as we know in the comfort
zone there's there's no growth in the
comfort zone
so it's interesting if you really don't
want to do it
well then you can keep being the guy
that's in the back and
guess what you're going to be mad in six
months when some other chef gets hired
for a different shift and all of a
sudden he's out
making friends with everyone he gets
promoted
and why does he get promoted well look
what the guy's doing but he's not as
good as
he's not as good as a cook as i am
guess what they don't really care being
making the food is only part of what
they want you to do just like being a
seal
doing the doing missions is only part of
what they what you need to do to do the
mission
you can't just be tactically sound
you've got to have the relationships
built so you can work in the battle
space
that's owned by a conventional commander
you got to have the relationship that
you can get your missions approved up
the chain of command on the special
operations side
how do you do that you build you go out
you talk to people you get
out of your comfort zone we lie
to ourselves we don't tell ourselves the
way things really are
and when we do that then we can't fix
our problems
if we can't fix our problems we're not
going to improve so we have to be
truthful to ourselves
i have to be truthful to myself you have
to be truthful to yourself
you have to stop rationalizing stop
making excuses
stop telling yourself little watered
down assessments
of where you're really at tell yourself
the truth
so that you can get where you want to go
you can be who you want to be you can be
who you should be
who you should be when you do what you
know you should do
when you pay attention to the little
things when you implement
discipline true and unflinching and
unmitigated discipline in your life
when you stop when you stop trying to
find a sweatless
solution when you look for weaknesses to
work on
when you allow no easy excuses
and all that starts when you stop lying
to yourself
when you stop lying to yourself that's
when you can become
who you know you should be when you tell
yourself the truth
about where you are so you can make sure
you are
in the right place and if you're not in
the right place that you can get
yourself on the path to get there
the path of discipline the path of hard
work
and the path of
truth you know something i realized so
as leif and i have been talking about
why we wrote the book the dichotomy of
leadership
why we picked that topic and what we've
been saying
is most of the questions that we would
get asked would be about the dichotomy
of leadership
that's completely true but i'll tell you
on top of that
more important most of the answers that
i give
are that there's a dichotomy in
leadership and you need to be balanced
that is what you even today i got asked
at camp
hey jocko i'm a white belt but i want to
be default aggressive
but i also hear you tell me to relax all
the time which one is it what do you
want me to do should i be default
aggressive and get after it
yeah or you you tell me relax and i
actually you know i say relax
harder right you got to relax harder
which one do you want me to do
and i said well luckily and life's there
too i'm like luckily
for this very reason life and i just
wrote a book called the dichotomy of
leadership and there's a dichotomy with
aggression
even though i say default aggressive and
i say that's got to be your mindset
that's going to be your default builders
you're going to be aggressive and you're
going to go get after it
and there's a chapter in the book you
that doesn't mean that you run to your
death
right you have to balance that with
caution
with with energy conservation
with not wasting movement on the mat
with not wasting capital in business
without burning bridges like all those
things you
have to be balanced that they're part of
your unit i mean obviously you were
a commander on a unit you were not a bri
battalion commander you were a commander
still you had people that are reporting
to you constantly
how can you differentiate between
somebody that could be a leader
of your unit versus somebody that needs
a lot of hand holding were there trends
that you saw were there certain things
that you were looking at again this is
one of those things where i mean
you know you can look at a person you
can do an assessment and i do pretty
good with my assessment you've been in
business for a long time you you
you're in the army you know you do
pretty good with your assessment but
you're you're only batting
60 how many times you hired somebody you
thought was going to knock it out of the
park and
two months later you end up firing them
long list it's a long list right how
many times you've
yeah you know what i'll give a guy a
shot and then they end up being a great
person
you know you get right some of the times
you know probably 60 70
of the time maybe even more but you
definitely can't guarantee anything and
that's why i look at everyone
with an open mind i look at people with
an open mind so not only do you know
i want you to be humble if you want to
learn but i'm looking at you with an
open mind i'm not looking at you
putting you in a box and thinking oh he
doesn't really have this capability i'm
looking you're like okay
let's hope he has the capability and if
he does we're going to build on it we're
going to turn him into
into into a solid leader don't press
snooze
snooze doesn't help by the way snooze is
one of those things it just seems he's a
dream killer
yeah it's like the snooze bottom and
kill your dreams that's why that's the
answer
yeah it's like a complete i think it's
gonna help you dream more but it's not
it's gonna destroy your dreams
it's a whole psychological choice if you
press
news the thing that you think expressing
the snooze helps you with like
just get that extra eight minutes of
sleep that eight minutes of sleep
doesn't give you any more energy by the
way
18 seconds there's there's an 18 second
window
in the morning when your alarm goes off
that sucks
it's about 18 seconds so 18 like the
alarm goes off and you touch it
yeah the next 18 seconds are like hard
that's when you have to use maximum
effort to clear the gravitational pull
of your pillow
if you can get away from those 18
seconds then
you're okay you just get a get away from
the pillow it's pulling you in
some tractor b you need to get away from
that so that 18 seconds and once you're
up and you're moving you're good
if i'm tired today if i wake up in the
morning
it's 4 30 and i'm like man i am wicked
tired and i don't feel like doing this
today
i what i do is i note it down in my head
like okay
you are tired then i go do it anyways
and if i'm tired the next day if the
next day i say the same thing
then i'm like okay you know what that's
two days in a row
your workout was weak i'm paying
attention and like okay guess what you
need a little downtime
that's that's the way i do it i won't
accept like the one thing in the world
i'll procrastinate
is procrastination like if i want to
take a day off
it's like okay the other thing about
this is
is you know this idea of quitting right
this idea of quitting and never quitting
and and people can confuse that
because if i'm in charge or if i'm in
charge of a
squad and it's like hey we're gonna
we're gonna go assault that
that bunker on the top of the hill okay
there's a bunker on top of hill with a
machine gun in it my squad we're gonna
go assault it
would we charge uphill to an elevated
position i know there's a lot of vets in
here what's gonna happen
okay yeah two or three of us get killed
like that
you know what we never quit go again
two or three more guys die go again
everyone's dead
did i never quit i never quit did i fail
my mission
yes i did so you have to keep track of
like what's my long-term goal
my long-term goal isn't to take that
machine gun nest it's to win the war
so if you're doing something on a daily
basis and you start feeling casualties
you need to assess yourself and say you
know you can have a business idea and
i've talked to a bunch of people like
this
they got that business idea and their
mindsets i'm never going to quit
well then they're running out of money
not just money for their business
money for their family and it's like
okay
hey if you've got it what what
adjustments can you make strategically
because the pattern that you're going
right now if you keep charging up that
hill with that
business the way you are everyone dies
if you say you know what time for tackle
retreat time for me to step back
time for me to call up some firepower to
come and help
drop some bombs on this target or get
some fire support
whatever the case may be so
keep that in mind as well sometimes you
get
overwhelmed there's just too many things
going on and you start to feel
like you're getting beat like you're
losing the battle
and when that happens to me what i like
to do is i like to
go on the hardcore offense
so i i just call it a sprint i will
sprint hard i'll
i'll take the things that i have to get
done for work and i will just
pile them up and i will work 2 or 3
12 16 18 hour days
to get caught up it's a lot better for
me to suffer
hard for three days and grind than to
suffer the continual burden that's
weighing on your back for months on end
don't let that happen
if you get a little bit behind and you
need to get caught up
hit the turbo button go hard for three
or four days
get yourself where you need to be
anthony bourdain obviously he was
about as successful as
as anyone could be i mean
he was a successful guy in so many
aspects and yet
and yet he killed himself he said in
this book i wanted
adventures i wanted to go up the nung
river
to the heart of darkness in cambodia
i wanted to ride out into a desert
on camelback sand and dunes in every
direction
eat whole roasted lamb with my fingers
i wanted to kick snow off my boots in a
mafia nightclub in russia
i wanted to play with automatic weapons
in phnom penh
recapture the past in a small oyster
village in france
step into a seedy neon lit pulkorea
in rural mexico
i wanted to run roadblocks in the middle
of the night blowing past angry militia
with a handful of hurled marble packs
[Music]
experience fear excitement wonder
i wanted kicks
the kind of melodramatic thrills and
chills
i'd yearned for since childhood
the kind of adventure i'd found as a
little boy in the pages of my tin tin
comic books
i wanted to see the world and i wanted
the world
to be just like the movies
that's what anthony bourdain said
just like the movies
[Music]
but you know what to me
the world is not like the movies
the movies aren't real they don't exist
[Music]
but you do
and life this life is
it's better than any movie there is
movies are supposed to provoke emotion
they're supposed to make you feel
something
but i have a better idea go out into the
world and
actually feel it
go feel joy and love
and triumph and rapture
and ecstasy and glory go feel those
things
and you know with those feelings
there will be other feelings as well
there'll be sorrow
and pain and sadness and desolation
and suffering
there'll be all those feelings too but
you know what
that's okay
that's okay take both sides
feel all of it that's what life is those
feelings those emotions those highs
and those lows those are life
and as i talk about taking ownership of
things you know when i get done talking
to people
i'll get done and someone will come up
to me and they'll say hey
you know i i really liked what you said
about
about ownership now if i could just get
my
team to take ownership we'd be good to
go
[Music]
and then someone up they also come up to
me and say hey hey i really liked what
you said about ownership that was really
cool man
i appreciate it and i i really hope my
co-workers
heard you because if they would just
take ownership we'd be good to go
and then someone will come up to me and
say hey man i really like that whole
thing about extreme ownership
and i really hope that my boss was
listening because if i could just get my
boss to take ownership
we'd be good to go
and then i always have to make it
crystal clear to them
that i'm not talking about their team
and i'm not talking about their
co-workers
and i'm not talking their boss i'm
talking about you
i'm talking about you the only person
that you can actually control you
that's who has to take ownership that's
who has to step up own everything
and lead i work with a lot of different
millennials in a lot of different
industries
they work hard and they get after it and
they're super successful and
millennials in the military have been
doing a great job so to think that
society's gotten harder now
on people i i don't really buy into that
life's hard if you want to be successful
you're gonna have to work hard
it's not just gonna show up you're gonna
have to dig
you have to wake up early and stay up
late
that's the way it works you gotta be
willing to do
things that your enemy is not willing to
do
that your competitor is not willing to
do yes i wake up early
yes i wake up at 4 30 in the morning
guess what you got 24 hours in a day the
earlier you get up the more you can take
advantage of those hours
the more you get up before the enemy or
your competitor
or actually in some cases your family
and friends the more stuff you can get
done
before they all start bothering you what
you should do if you want to start
waking up early
is start waking up early you figure out
what that time is for you and then you
start waking up at that time
now if you wake up and it's earlier than
you normally wake up by the end of the
day guess what
you'll be a little bit more tired and
then you can go to bed a little bit
earlier
and you continue with that pattern until
you get a good
fixated time of going to bed and waking
up the other
piece of this is on the weekends people
think oh great it's the weekend now i
can sleep in
negative don't sleep in on the weekends
when you sleep in the weekends you know
on saturday
you sleep in until 6 30 in the morning
well now you're not tired at night so
you stay up a little bit
later and then on sunday you sleep in
until eight
and by the time monday morning rolls
around you stayed up until midnight
and now you don't feel like waking up
early so
get up early and get up early every day
get a workout in take care of your
health i guarantee
your day will go better give it a shot
we lie
to ourselves we don't tell ourselves the
way things really are
and when we do that then we can't fix
our problems
if we can't fix our problems we're not
going to improve so we have to be
truthful to ourselves
you have to stop rationalizing stop
making excuses
stop telling yourself little watered
down assessments
of where you're really at tell yourself
the truth
so that you can get where you want to go
you can be
who you want to be who you should be
when you do what you know you should do
when you pay attention to the little
things
when you implement discipline
true and unflinching and unmitigated
discipline in your life
when you stop trying to find a sweatless
solution
when you look for weaknesses to work on
and all that starts
when you stop lying to yourself
that's when you can become who you know
you should be
when you tell yourself the truth about
where you are
so you can make sure you are in the
right place and if you're not
in the right place then you can get
yourself on the path to get there
the path of discipline the path of hard
work
and the path of truth
as a leader you have to be balanced
right you have to be balanced so
let's just take humility and ego because
we're looking for people that are humble
but at the same time
you can have someone that's so humble
that they lack confidence
that's bad on the other side of that
spectrum you can have someone that's
so confident that they're overconfident
their ego is big and they don't listen
to anyone else
where do you want to be you want to be
balanced somewhere in the middle
i talked about the fact that you need to
be articulate as a leader that's great
can you be a leader that talks so much
that people
stop listening to you the other end of
the spectrum is you are a leader that
doesn't say enough and now the team
doesn't know
what direction they're supposed to be
going in so where do you want to be you
want to be somewhere
in the middle you want to be balanced
make your luck yeah
you got to make your luck and if you
make it if you keep
if you keep putting forth the maximal
effort that luck's going to come you're
going to make your luck happen
you know that you know that actually
when we
when we came when tasking a bruiser came
home from
iraq there was there was you know people
like oh you guys got super lucky
on that deployment because we got a lot
of action right
and there was two like immediate
thoughts behind that was number one like
hey you know
first of all we lost our bros like
they're nothing lucky about that
was the first immediate thought in my
head was like hey man
like because the bottom line is seals
want to go into combat
bad and that's just a broad statement
and so when we came home had been in a
lot of combat
and killed a lot of bad guys and
people were kind of saying hey you guys
got
lucky and and again the first thought
was
hey man if this is luck i don't want it
the second thought was just like
the same thing like oh we got lucky we
didn't
like crush ourselves in the work up and
try and be the most you know
prepared we could be and then get
overseas and form relationships with all
the conventional forces
and do good work for them and continue
to you know
just get go as hard as we could the
whole time no that didn't have anything
to do with it was just luck and it kind
of fell into our lap
but you know of course just nod your
head and say thanks man appreciate it
yeah
good times so
luck is definitely a part of it a little
part
because was i lucky to be in ramadi
because i could have deployed a year
later and a year later ramadi was
passified so is there luck there there
absolutely is
so i don't want to sound arrogant but
luck is a part it's like foot locks it's
like
heel hooks sure they're a part of the
game they're not a game changer
what is the difference between an excuse
and a reason hmm
kind of a good question right sure
okay and the reason it's a good question
because there's there can be legitimate
reasons why
things happen yeah right and
so for instance you're in a in a sailing
race
right in a sailboat and the mast
snaps in half now you don't win the race
but
i mean you didn't you know the mast
snapped
what can you do about that or the
weather's the
horrible weather rolls in and you can't
launch your aircraft so you can't go on
your mission
you can't control the weather so you
know like what's up
how can that that's a reason or you get
really sick so you can't
compete in a competition that's a reason
you know you were saying oh you do bad
because you were sick and you
it's a reason could be called now
now you could look at the situation and
say
okay if i'm going to take ownership of
this did i properly test the mast
sure did i let me ask you this did we
have a ground-based plan
for the operation in case the weather
came in we were going to take
vehicles instead right
yeah that would work if you get sick
before the competition maybe you ask
yourself
were you resting properly were you
eating properly going into the
competition so you wouldn't get
sick you could
address that correct yes sir so
you can still take ownership of things
even if the
initial reaction is like oh there's you
can't control that well you can
influence it you can mitigate it right
now can there still be legitimate
reasons
yes there can and for me the the
the difference the line between an
excuse
and a reason is
a reason you have zero control over
right you you just have zero control
over something happening well that's a
reason
did i tell you i was almost late the
other day for something
uh no because this is borderline this is
borderline uh-huh i had an appointment
at ten o'clock
i left is a 20-minute drive
i left an hour i left at
well i left about 9 10. i left 50
minutes
to drive 20 minutes just so gonna make
it on time
yeah yeah i get on the road basically
a couple roads out of my house and the
one entry
way to get on the freeway is lock down
lock down like incident like isolate
some incidents
a guy trying to kill himself okay on a
bridge shut the road down
yeah so no one's going on the highway so
what is it
everyone's being channelized into
marginal what are they called back side
streets yeah yeah detours
re-route the clock is ticking
and and i made it
right i made it i was four minutes i had
four minutes to spare so instead of
taking 20 minutes it took whatever 46
minutes took more than twice as long
that that could be you know
a fairly legitimate
reason now luckily i had i always you
know
i had planned that there could be
something out of my control it might
take even longer
and that's why i leave early to go to an
appointment
or a situation like that so
i could have also checked the traffic
prior to leaving and taking a completely
different route
that would have been i blame myself so
even in that situation i'm kind of i i
was thinking the whole time
what why did why didn't i check the
traffic before i left i knew this could
have happened
so what's the number one thing you look
for in a leader
well the first book was called extreme
ownership and what that means is
you're not gonna make any excuses you're
not gonna blame anyone else you're gonna
take ownership
of whatever happens and when something
goes wrong instead of pointing fingers
and blaming someone else you're gonna
take ownership of that problem
you're gonna take ownership of figuring
out what the solution to that problem is
and you're going to take ownership of
implementing that solution so that is
the number one thing that i'm looking
for for a leader to do is to take
ownership of the problems
and again we call that extreme ownership
and it was one of those things that was
very easy to see in a seal platoon
because when someone doesn't take
ownership and starts pointing fingers
and blaming
well like for instance right now if i
started pointing my finger and blaming
you for something what's your natural
reaction going to be and get defensive
get upset i mean
it's not my fault this broadcast isn't
what i wanted it to be exactly exactly
and then what happens is we have a team
where you're pointing i'm pointing the
finger at you you're putting the finger
to someone else and now we have
no one taking ownership of the problems
and therefore the problems never get
solved
the opposite of that is when you have a
good leader that steps up and says hey
ben you know what this broadcast didn't
go the way i wanted to i should have
done a better job preparing to for your
questions i'm sorry i apologize
and now instead of you getting defensive
you say you know what no actually i
could have done a better job
and now both of us are taking ownership
of the problems and we're going to get
them solved
if you're blaming everyone else i can't
control you
i can't control these other things
outside i can't i can't control
the only thing i can control is me so
instead of worrying about
who else is causing you problems worry
about what you can do to yourself to
improve your station
and if you go down that path you're
gonna find you have a lot more control
than you think you do
how many people are like involved in a
startup right now they're starting up
right
cool so a startup is like a little kid
right it's got all this potential
it's got all this potential what happens
with a little kid
that never gets disciplined
yeah little kids that don't get
disciplined
turn into satan that's what happens
and guess what now in the beginning
like a startup like a baby when you got
a baby you got to do everything for it
in the beginning you got to hold its
head you got to make sure everything's
perfect the way
whatever it takes to get that thing keep
that thing alive you got to do it
but once that thing starts to expand
well then
you better start imposing some
discipline on it or else that thing will
turn into
satan when i go up to origin and i get
to go in the factory and
see the people that that are working
hard and they work hard
every day every day and they put their
heart and soul into
making these products that's that's an
unbelievable thing to say
and it got taken away you know that got
taken away
and to be in this situation now
where we're literally able to bring it
back
that actually means something we're not
taking our foot off the gas
we're going to go harder we're going to
push more we're going to get involved in
more
it's going to be a grind there's risk
you know we're putting
our money in to buy machines that
are are covered in dust because we
believe and
if you believe in something you take the
risk that's what you do
and that's what we're doing and you know
what
we're going to win when i was getting
ready to retire
a guy that i knew was a friend of mine
he was the ceo of a company
and he said hey can you come and talk to
my executives you know about about
combat leadership
and i said you know sure i'll do it he's
a friend of mine
so i went and did it and i don't know
what he thought i was going to talk
about
but when i got done he came up to me and
said
i want you to do this for every division
that i have in my company and i said
well i'm retiring and i don't know and
he said i'll give you money and i said
how much and we worked it out and i
ended up talking to every division that
he had in his company and at one of
those divisional meetings
the ceo of the parent company was there
and when i got done
you know briefing about leadership that
ceo came up to me and said hey i want
you to talk to
the ceos of all my companies and you
know he owned
45 or 50 companies and from there i went
and talked to those ceos
and the next thing you know i i had a i
had a new job
you know and i didn't get to retire like
i had planned when i was a young
i was i enlisted in the navy out of high
school and i was the youngest guy in my
first i was the youngest and most junior
guy in my first two seal platoons
and what i was doing was i was looking
at my leaders
and i was watching them and i was paying
attention to what they were doing
and i was paying attention to why we
liked this guy and why we wanted to
follow this guy but why we didn't like
this guy we didn't want to follow him
the biggest characteristic i noticed of
that was guys that were humble we wanted
to follow
guys that were arrogant we didn't want
to follow but that was
one of many many little lessons
and i paid attention to it
once i moved into a leadership position
i knew that all those guys
they were watching me they were paying
attention to me
and i had to think about the way
that they were going to react to what i
was doing and i knew
that my job was to lead these guys
and i knew that they were taking notes
and they were monitoring
and they were testing and if i was
arrogant they weren't going to follow me
if i thought i knew everything they
weren't going to follow me i'm not
saying i couldn't be confident because
yeah you have to be confident there's a
balance it's dichotomy leadership right
but you have to pay attention to those
around you to the people that work for
you
the people that work that you work for
and you monitor what they're doing
and you process what you would follow
and what you wouldn't
and then you emulate that that's what i
did
that's what i'm most importantly still
doing today
when people ask me all the time like hey
do you ever take days off
and my answer is i take days off i don't
schedule them
but days off happen why because life
happens right
sick kid water heater breaks uh you know
a car has a flat tire
can't get where i'm supposed to be boom
guess what you just bought yourself a
day
a downtime now like travel day if you
got
i get some flights that are whatever
they can leave here at 6 15 in the
morning from san diego
and sometimes i had a late night for me
to get up at
3 30 to get a workout in it's actually
counterproductive
i'm i'm smoking myself so then i'll be
like okay guess what
you just got a day off it just came
that being said people also ask me what
do you do when you're sick
what do you do when you're tired you
know what and this is a real simple
answer
do what you can but you rudy you're just
telling me you didn't have a chance to
work out today
you're in the in the room over there
doing push-ups why do what you can
you maintain that discipline people want
to sleep in on the weekends
negative negative
don't sleep in on the weekends the
weekends when you got to hold the line
the weekends when you got to hold the
line if you sleep in on the weekend
till 5 45 well then guess what at night
you all of a sudden you have a little
extra energy so you stay up a little
later
so then sunday morning you sleep until 6
30. now monday rolls around that alarm
goes off at 4 30 and you don't feel like
doing it
and you start this downward spiral right
now hey people
look don't get me wrong
all right you gotta sleep you gotta
sleep sleep is very healthy it's good
for you
what i am saying you don't need to get
up at 4 30. you don't need to do that
people have different schedules
you got your life going on you got to
figure out what works for you but i am
absolutely saying don't be lazy i am
absolutely saying
get on a get on a regular pattern and
maintain that pattern
to the best of your ability how do we
make good decisions well
number one making correct decisions you
got to study you got to know and
understand you got to know the
background
you've got to know the historical
outcomes
of equivalent type decisions that have
happened in the past
similar situations and if you know
the history and you know the background
then
you can use those to assess the current
situation you're in
and then once you assess the decisions
that you can make assess the possible
actions that you can take and then
assess the outcomes
that those decisions will have those
actions will have
and when you're doing that you also have
to assess the
possibilities of inaction so a lot of
times people forget that one they don't
know they don't know if they should do a
or b
what they forget is there's also what if
i don't do either what's going to happen
sometimes not doing either is good most
or a lot of times not doing either is
bad
so you got a or b what should you do
maybe sometimes you got to pick a or b
sometimes occasionally it's better not
to do anything
and you wait and let the situation
develop a little bit more
what so the point of this is whatever
you can know beforehand
you know you learn you study you
understand
you know the standard operating
procedures you know what variance
variations have been made on the
standard operating procedures
and that's how you go forward as leaders
i see people getting caught up all the
times in
little things that will not affect the
outcome unless they let it
so i see some white belt
blow them in the chain of command's
going all crazy grabbing their sleeve
and this
leader on the top like gets concerned
about it and puts time and effort into
something
that doesn't matter whether it's a
little personality rub a little
ego uprising it's like should we do it
this way or should we do it that way it
doesn't matter that's a little sleeve
grab it doesn't
matter and i see people getting caught
up on things that don't
matter all the time and what i've
realized
is it's something that i figured out
a long time ago i don't know when but a
long time ago i figured out you know
what
that thing doesn't matter i'm not going
to worry about it that thing doesn't
matter i'm not going to worry about it
that thing doesn't matter i'm not going
to
worry about it that thing matters i'm
going to focus on that thing
and that makes that makes a big
a big big big difference it's it's
leadership capital
because if i'm investing my leadership
capital and getting your hand off my
sleeve
or trying to do it my way instead of
your way or trying to keep your ego in
check
if that's what i'm investing my
leadership capital is i have nothing
left to invest in the thing that
actually matters do you think that it
really is that leadership is is born or
is it bread yeah i get asked this
question all the time
and so it's both it's absolutely both
and you
as a human being are going to get
certain characteristics
that are going to make you a good leader
and you're going to lack some
characteristics that would make you a
good leader if you had them
you don't get tens across the board you
know it's like the little video games
you see kids play where you get uh
a nine in strength and a and a seven an
intellect and a
and an eight in dexterity and you get
those too as a leader
and you don't get all tens so some
leadership
characteristics that make you a good
leader for instance obviously it's good
to be articulate
if you can express your message clearly
to people that's gonna that's gonna help
you from a leadership perspective
if you have some natural charisma that's
going to help you from a leadership
perspective
if you can look at complex problems and
you can simplify them
that's going to be helpful as a leader
because that's what you're doing
so if you're persuasive there's all
kinds of things that will help you as a
leader and you're not going to be good
at all of them
and so as a leader if you look at the
ones that you're weak at
you can improve them that's that's
what's beneficial so you can't take
someone that's
just a horrible leader and make them
into an amazing leader but you can take
someone that's a decent leader and you
can make them into a very good or even
an exceptional leader
because you know you can definitely get
more articulate you can definitely get
more
comfortable speaking to people you can
definitely get more
more precise at taking
very complex problems and simplifying
them so that your team can understand
what it is that needs to get done
so these are all things that you can
improve upon and i always have to
close this out by saying that there are
some people
that cannot become better leaders and
the people that cannot become better
leaders
are the people that can't put their ego
in check they lack humility
and those people they think they're
doing everything great so they're not
going to improve as leaders
you can't coach them you can't convince
them they think they're perfect and
they're going to stay where they are
from a leadership perspective the things
that i'm supposed to be doing aren't
getting done no one's going to do them
for me
and that's the way it's going to be
right now if i'm
laying in bed not only am i letting
myself down i'm letting down
everybody that's on board everybody
that's in the game
and i'm not going to let them down it's
not happening you're not able to predict
exactly what's going to happen so what
do you do you keep grinding
don't know why things happen always but
i do know this
when the opportunities are there you
gotta go
if i tell you echo hey echo i want you
to do this mission i want you to do it
this way take your platoon and go do it
and you disagree with what i'm telling
you
and you just say hey boss i don't want
to do it that way and i said hey
you shut up and do what i told you to do
and you go you know what
you can fire me but i'm not doing it i
go okay fine you're fired and i get
knucklehead over here who's the yes man
it comes in and i tell him to go to the
mission the way i told him to do it and
he goes and does and gets everyone
killed
would it have been better off if you
said okay boss i get it
i i'll do it your way here's some things
i'd really like to not do
and you go no i said no shut up and then
you take your guys you mitigate
everything that you can
actually there's an example of this in
band of brothers where
major winners is being told hey send a
reconnaissance element across the river
again tonight and he doesn't want to do
it
the the war is almost over they had
taken some casualties i think the night
before when they did the same type of
operation and he just says
got it boss and then the guys go and
they
sit in a they pretend to go out but they
really just sit in the basement of a
building
on their side of the river and then
later on they say yep we went we came
back we didn't find anything okay cool
there's a perfect example um imagine if
if major winners dick winters was like
we're not doing it
and now you're getting an ego contest
with the colonel he was like oh yes you
are
no we're not okay fine you're fired let
me get knucklehead over here
yeah who's gonna do what i told him to
do who's a total yes man
and now we take that risk and guys get
killed so so
who is it there's a there's dick winners
played the game
he played the game so he could still
have that influence in power
and and still protect his guys yeah
you can get complex yeah it's it's very
that's why leadership is hard
yes it's it's weird though because when
you say it's complex when you say
leadership is hard
at the same time like you if you're a
principled human being and you have
principles and you know what's right and
you're doing the right thing for the
right reason
the decisions are actually usually a
little easier
clearer like clearer yeah they might not
be easy but they're clearer
like i know what i'm supposed to do here
yeah i got it yeah i'm i'm gonna figure
this one out
and it's easy to justify your yourself
you know like you're you're let's say
okay i'm real good at fitness
you know i'm a fitness guru and i go
around and then i see
i don't know i go to the store or go to
some party and
i see this other guy who's like socially
he's just a hundred percent everyone
likes me such a nice
charismatic guy he makes a lot of money
you know and all this stuff
but he's not in that good shape or i
don't know he smokes and whatever you
know
the it's ease i think a lot of people
it feels like it's easy to justify well
that guy's in bad shape so who cares i
wouldn't want any of that i wouldn't
want all the money you know all this
stuff
it seems like you can just justify that
and you know what the other guy's saying
yeah you might be in good shape guess
what yeah nice
toyota corolla you're driving he's all
negative on him yeah
yeah yeah so both those guys should
it should instead of saying hey you know
what they should do walk up and be like
hey man you know what i notice you're
pretty successful financially
i would like to get in the game with you
a little bit and and
learn from you about that and the other
guy should say to him well you know what
it looks like you're in pretty good
fitness levels i would like to get in
the game with that
let's work together and improve
ourselves
and go out and kick ass and dominate are
you in i'm in
let's do this instead what does a normal
person do
they do exactly what you said justify
criticize
cut people down instead of building them
up
yeah and what you have to be careful of
if i was to go to you and say
hey you know echo i got a lot of money i
can tell you don't have a lot i'll help
you out that's
that can be offensive to some people
yeah because you think dude who you
think you are yeah yeah you're just
rising right back i'm gonna need your
help i'm not worried about money yeah
you think i'm worried about money when i
got abs like these
you know so what we have to do is
instead of if you if i came to you and
said echo
dude i want abs like you got sure can
you help me get in the game and then we
formed a little relationship and now i
say to you man
so what do you what you what's your main
income stream dude
you know what are you doing and you say
well you know i got these two clients
you got a website
no not really why don't you have a
website you got any social media to
advertise
you know we go that road and we build up
we take care of each other so we want to
do as people
yeah kind of like you ever see seen the
guys who go
they see like a football player or
something they'll be like i'd kick his
ass though
you know you know that kind guy who can
always like some successful person i
[Music]
if a guy like we have guys in the seal
teams that are literally
you know world-class athletes in
whatever
world-class triathlete world-class
sailor world-class whatever
and so oh you oh you're you're a
world-class triathlete
oh yeah that guy's really good
triathlete that's cool
he's a really bad shot someone is going
to chime in and cut him down
there are many times in life in the
world where showing your emotions are
going to have a negative
impact on your situation you're
you you give up the takedown in a
jiu-jitsu competition
and you show it in your face that person
just thinks i just broke you
right right you don't show any emotion
there boss tells you you're getting
stuck with the underperforming team
don't show any emotion right don't don't
oh man
no don't do that but hey what about this
there's a good one
boss is giving you feedback that you
don't agree with
roll your eyes you know what i mean the
the heavy sigh
the clenched teeth as you're trying to
listen with this person you don't even
respect him he's telling us
what's that gonna get you i'm not going
to get you anything
and showing that negative emotion there
you need to keep normal face in that
situation
your kid's doing something that's
annoying it's trying to test your
patience they're just trying to piss you
off
don't let them keep it in check
get told to go to the other line in dmv
after you've been waiting for an hour
and one don't freak out don't show any
emotions
got it here's here's another one
we already talked about this one your
friends are poke in front of you
because you missed a shot at the range
or you got lost on a land navigation
course or whatever
don't get all mad don't get frustrated
don't show any motion you know they make
fun of your haircut they make fun of
your accent they make fun of whatever
don't show emotions don't freak out
that's the other balance now there are
also times
where you might have to force yourself
to show some emotion
just to get the point across right your
kid hasn't listened to you after five or
six violations
you might have to show some anger or
they or they do something that's going
to get them hurt
right you gotta show some emotion so
that they realize that was real
but flying off the temper and flying off
the handle and losing your tempers
almost never does you any good so yeah
you have to be balanced in order to be
balanced you have to be in control and
in order to be being controlled you have
to detach from your emotions so you can
control your emotions and
not let your emotions control you
i was getting interviewed the other day
some interview
and the guy said something about like um
you know it's impressive however you
know quickly you've built your brand
right and i looked at them and i said
i'm not a brand i'm a person
i'm a person what i'm doing
is not what i'm doing so that i can
leverage
people what i do
is just me and i'm just a person
so if you asked me if i would wear a
rainbow t-shirt
i wouldn't no i've asked you to wear
lots of stuff when you have it
and if you asked me but but that's not
because
of i'm trying to be something it's
because that's who i am
right and i have been i had one of my
bros
who i hadn't seen in a while and
he we met at a little place we go to in
san diego
and i hadn't seen him in a year and a
half and
he comes walking in and he sees me and
i'm wearing the same thing that i always
wear
a pair of jeans a victory black t-shirt
and he walks in and he sees in a fight
it was wintertime and i was wearing a
flannel like a
whatever like a new england yeah like a
new england but like
cheap whatever flannel with the quilt
inside of it yeah
and um he sees me and like when he sees
me
and this is kind of you know after the
books in the podcast and he's
another seal so he's suspect
and he sees me and i see his face and
his face like
gets happy when he sees me and he
and he comes over and like does like a
bro hug
and he says bro you're exactly the same
and i was like yeah man and he goes i
knew it and like that to me
was the best compliment i'll ever get is
like
okay no matter what happens i'm not a
brand
i'm not doing anything for
you know any other reason other than
it's just me
and that's just just what i'm doing and
if people are cool with it man that's
awesome
if you're there and you're in a
leadership position or you're just in a
position you're in relationship whatever
and you're doing things for the team
you're trying to take care of the others
you're putting other people above you
in the end you're going to win
and you're going to win way bigger than
you could
if you were clawing and scratching and
ripping things and bringing them back to
yourself
the end that person that thinks that
thinks that they're doing the right
thing or thinks that they're doing
something good for themselves but what
they're really doing is taking things
from other people
that person they might get a couple
tactical victories along the way
but in the end the person that puts
everyone else first
is going to win they are going to win
so it's it's kind of hypocritical
because it's like in the one hand it's
like no i don't care about myself
i'm not trying to improve i'm not trying
to improve my station in life
but by doing that you will improve your
station in life and you'll improve your
station in life beyond
anything that you could have done if
your goal
was to improve your station in life if
you want more freedom in your life you
have to have more discipline
if you don't have any discipline you'll
end up with absolutely no freedom you'll
end up
being a slave to other people that boss
you around there's all kinds of problems
that can occur
if you don't have discipline in your
life and the more discipline you have
the more freedom you're going to have so
just the the discipline of the sales
will never it's impossible to leave no
it's possible to leave there's
there's retired seals all over the place
that are undisciplined they've moved on
and they don't care about that anymore
it's fine i don't judge other people on
what they're doing like they're probably
stoked to
sleep in and hang out with their kids
and eat breakfast in bed
that's fine i don't have anything
against that but for me i i want to get
up and
go how do i build trust with someone the
way i build trust with people is i
give them trust so if you're working for
me i say
hey uh you know i want you to do this
mission patrick
come up with a plan i'm showing you that
i trust what your plan is gonna be now
i'm gonna
i'm going to make sure that your plan is
good i'm going to review it but i'm
going to give you a lot of autonomy
i'm going to give you trust and when i
give you trust what's your reaction you
think to yourself this guy trusts me yep
and then the way i build trust and
reverses when you make a mistake instead
of me jumping down your throat
and hanging you out to dry instead i say
okay you know what
my fault i should have given i should
have given you better direction here's
what we're gonna do next time so now you
look at me and you go hey
i screwed this thing up and jocko still
trusts me i trust him
and that's how i build trust i give it
you give it i give trust to build trust
if i'm really putting an effort but my
plan maybe not the best plan
you're still going to give me second
chances to work on and get better at it
i will
micromanage you more i can't trust you
as much we do a business deal or
we're in business i don't send you out
with the biggest client i've got when i
just met you and say hey i trust you no
i give you a little client and i say hey
go go make this happen and you come back
and you say hey look i did it
i said great and you trust me a little
bit more or maybe you screw that one up
and i say okay let me review what you do
what mistakes got made
and you say oh well i did this and okay
we correct that but i don't
i don't come down hard on you because
i'm trying to build a relationship with
you if i come down hard on you do you
even want to work for me do you even
want to be if i come down
this is pathetic you screwed this up
this is your fault you're looking for
another job
whereas if i say okay let's look at what
we can do better then i'm building the
trust but can
you know you might be very trustworthy
for many years and then all of a sudden
you go out and you do something
underhanded with a client you try and
rip them off or rip me off
yeah i mean you're not gonna have trust
for me anymore what do i do
when i'm broken
when i'm broken
i relish it that's what i'm gonna do i'm
gonna use it
because if i'm broken then i just found
my limitations
and until i know what my limitations are
how can i push him
how can i get better
but once
once i see it once i feel it once i
see where i was broken then
i can attack that weakness i can
fill in that gap
i can reinforce that breach
if you break it means it's time to
fortify your will to make it stronger
then look there's there's all kinds of
different ways
to break you can break
physically you can break mentally you
can
break your heart you can break your
spirit and none of those are fun
and all of those are gonna leave a mark
but the mark that they leave
can be the mark of victory
or can be the mark of defeat
because every time you break and in
every way
that you break while it's a chance
it's definitely a chance for you to give
up and for you to
just to fall apart
but there's also opportunity
there's opportunity to get
stronger and get smarter and get faster
and get tougher and get more stable and
get more
resilient and get
better in fact if you break
the fight is just beginning
and as you crawl up
and out of that dismal and wretched
place covered and you're
covered in blood and sweat and
dirt and filth as you rise above
what you were
and as you take the form of
of who you are supposed to be
you will see that in the very act of
standing up in the very act of fighting
on
you will become and you will remain
unbroken you can't know how you're going
to conduct a war before the war starts
you can have an idea but you can't know
fully
just like if you were to say hey my goal
is to x in my life
you don't know how you're going to be
able to do that yeah because
you talk about because you got to adjust
because you're going to make an
adaptation things are going to come up
things are going to change the
battlefield
changes your life changes things pop up
i mean things happen so
i think that that idea that you're going
to know how you're going to execute
something
is is far-fetched i think
actually i should use the word idea you
should have an idea of how you're going
to do it yeah
you should have an idea like okay well
this is what i need to get done
this is what i want to achieve in my
life i want to make i want to do this
what's a simple one i want to own a
house that's a simple one that's a good
place to start yeah i want to own a
house
okay well let's think about how we're
going to get there
you know that's that's let's think about
how we're going to get there you have to
build your credit
you have to how do you build your credit
you have to you have to borrow money
some people
sometimes they go to buy a house they've
never borrowed money before you can't
borrow money if you've never borrowed
money you can't borrow money for a house
if you've never borrowed money for a car
or
a or some smaller object before so
you've got to establish your credit then
you've got to have two years worth of
income then you've got to have a big
fat down payment sitting ready so
there's things you've got to do this
thing now now that might change acro
along the way the idea is that you got
to move towards that goal but that's
what was so nice about hearing the
vietnamese commander's intent get close
split them up yeah boom you go make that
happen hey guess what you want to buy a
house one day
save money have good credit yeah okay
well you got to make money how are you
going to make money you might make it
drive an uber you might make it
delivering pizza
you might make because you got your real
job with that support in your family but
then you need a little extra to throw in
there well that's why you end up driving
uber you end up with whatever it is
you're going to do you're right you make
your
some money on the side that you can
start stashing away in a way you got to
fill your life with a bunch of goals
so you don't get gym because like yes
you have small goals that lead to the
big goal
right so for instance you want to be
financially secure and stable what are
you going to do you're going to save
some of your money okay that's one thing
you're going to buy a house that's
another thing you're going to pay off
your car and you're not going to buy
expensive
dumb cars you're going to buy cheap cars
until you have the money to buy them
with cash
you know you're going to make all these
little things you're going to work extra
you're going to you know you're going to
do these things so you're right you have
you have your broad goal yes you have
your long-term goal yes and then you've
got your short-term goals that lead
and are strategically aligned with that
long-term goal i just got asked this
question the other day young uh
uh construction business and
a kid we were in a big meeting with with
a bunch of leadership
from foreman to engineers
all in the same room bunch of great guys
from a great company
and one of the young engineers raised
his hand and said you know i'm
young and i am going to be in charge of
these guys
you know i'm not sure i'm comfortable
with these guys i've been doing it for a
lot longer what can i do to
you know gain their respect and i said
okay
who in this room knows more than that
engineer back there
about construction and all these salty
construction foremans raised their hands
and i said who you know who's gonna
think that this guy's got the best idea
raise your hands all the hands go down
and i said so this is what you're
dealing with buddy
i said now let me ask another question
the group group
if this kid comes in and says i know how
to do this better
than you listen to me and do it my way
who's gonna have respect for him raise
your hand no hands go up
if this young kid comes in and says hey
i'm an engineer i've been educated but i
haven't been doing this for long
can you give me some recommendations on
how we do this so we can do the best job
possible who's gonna have respect for
them
everyone raises their hand so there you
have it
you you you don't have to know
everything as a leader
no one expects you know everything
especially as a young leader that's okay
and actually when you admit that you
actually gain respect
when you ask for people's input you
actually gain respect people get the
paranoid feeling
that if they don't know something
they're going to be seen as weak
it's not true so
you can just step up into the position
still be humble
still take advice now this doesn't mean
that you're a pushover
right this doesn't mean that you just
listen to what everyone says you don't
make any decisions no
it actually means that you show respect
to their experience and when it comes
time to make a decision
you get the best input and then you make
a decision and you explain your decision
and if your decision is wrong you admit
it and if it's not wrong you push
forward
so that's what you need to do you're
getting asked to be put in this position
for a reason
so do it i kind i look like a serial
killer for all practical purposes
i'm that's the way i come across right
it's not creepy enough there's
there's guys that would um you know
guys that would work for me or guys that
would be around me and they'd see me and
they'd kind of
latch on to the fact that i was tough
and aggressive
and and and some of those guys they
wouldn't catch the other part
which was that i was politically savvy
and i was working and i was
maneuvering and i was you know figuring
things out
and talking to my boss in such a way
that we could get where we needed to be
and
i was doing that whole other side and so
i get these guys that would end up
not doing as well as they should do
because they were just hey jocko is just
ultra aggressive and he gets after it
and so that's what i'm gonna do and i'll
be in the same place
the guys that would do well the guys
that said oh yeah jacqua's awesome and
he's aggressive and he gets after it
he's also working and he's also
maneuvering he's also massaging the egos
of the people around him so make sure
that they get positioned in the right
spot where they can go to war pause in
the right way
and and so as i've gotten older i've
been able to tell people that more
clearly like hey
it's not just about that side of the
ultra aggressive
you got to be aggressive you got to be
willing to fight you got to be willing
to kill and you got to be willing to die
at the same time you got to be able to
tamper and temper all those
things in such a way that they can be
controlled and disciplined
there's people that quit drinking and
quit doing drugs
and quit losing their temper and i've
heard
from so many different people that have
implemented
change in their lives so so many letters
and messages and notes and i want you to
know that these people aren't a bunch of
of elite special operations warriors
that's not
who who they are they aren't a bunch of
high level
athletes or highly screened
and highly trained individuals
these are just just normal people really
but they're normal people that knew
they needed to make a change
and they decided they were going to make
a change
and then they made it
and that
is what i do and that is what
you can do too if you have
something to change if you want to
change
something change it
change it
[Music]
now so what you have to be do what you
have to do
is don't be offensive when you take
ownership
when you take ownership you can't be
offensive
[Music]
when you take ownership some people get
offended by that
so when you say hey you know what this
is mine i got this
that bothers some people when you say
you know what this is my fault and i'm
gonna fix it that even that
offends some people what the tone just
the tone yeah of like
no this is hey my fault i got this and
you do that three to
three times four times five times and
also because oh what everything's his
fault
he's got to fix everything they he
doesn't think i can fix it right
you can offend people with a with with
all kinds of stuff
you have to work very hard to offend
people i mean there's people get
offended when you say something nice to
them
even when you're taking ownership people
can
actually be offended by that if you go
too far
so instead of overtly stepping up and
taking ownership in this particular case
then you can tell what's going on here
my brother here
young warehouse manager he's fired up he
wants to make things happen he wants to
get after it
and so what does he do he's like oh i
read extreme ownership i'm going to take
ownership of everything and that's a
great attitude to have
except for you can offend people when
you go too far because you got to read
the second book that i got into
leadership
so that you could you can balance that
out a little bit so instead of saying
like
hey this is mine i'm going to take
ownership of this and make it happen
instead you know you look at someone you
you say hey you know what
do you want me to take care of this oh
hey you know what that's probably in my
department you want me to take care of
that so that way
or like hey it seems like this should be
something i should take care of you want
me to handle that
instead of me me me
i'm a 17 year old i'm a blue belt in jiu
jitsu which i received a few days after
my 16th birthday
and i have ambitions of pursuing jiu
jitsu professionally and competing to
the highest level possible
of course this requires discipline and
commitment i miss parties and social
events in order to train jiu jitsu and
weight train
because i know that i should have the
discipline to do so
however i feel lonely and isolated
because of it
is this just weakness or should i make
the occasional exception for a social
event
if you can't like communicate with
people effectively that's a real problem
in any environment
right and if you're isolating yourself
from other people
and you're not you're not learning how
to interact with other human beings
in a social environment that's not good
and it's not only it's not only that
it's
it's not only that it's just not good
for you because yes you as a person you
need to be well-rounded you need
yes you need to be strong you need to be
capable from a fighting perspective
but you also need to be smart you need
to be articulate you need to be
quick-witted
and those things are mandatory skills in
life
i mean if you're a black belt in jiu
jitsu and you're a white belt and
communicating with other human beings
that's not going to be a good situation
for you
and the other thing is the better you
are the more well-rounded you are in all
these other aspects of life those things
will actually make you better at
jiu-jitsu because you'll be able to read
people
you'll be able to deal with
confrontation you'll be able to
understand other people's motivations
and all those things come from
interacting with other human beings
so i get it i get
the massive commitment and that is what
it takes like if you want to
compete at the highest level i'm telling
you yes you have to live breathe and eat
jiu jitsu
you have to live breathe and eat
conditioning
and that being said if that's all you
live breathe and eat
that's gonna make you less
apt to be a champion than if you
make yourself a little bit more
well-rounded in some of these other
aspects
you can put so much working so much
focus on working that you lose track of
your family
yeah and everything goes down deal with
your family or you can do the opposite
put so much focus on your family
that you lose track of that you don't do
what you're supposed to do at work
so you need to back off a little and you
get people that waste
time on things that don't matter this
goes back remember the podcast we did
where i was talking about
how like a black belt when a white
belt's clapping grabbing a black belt
sleeve
and it just doesn't matter there's
people that think
that it's important that i do this thing
this certain way
and the reality is it's useless it
doesn't matter you're being ocd
right you're being ocd so or you're
maybe not being fellowship but you're
being borderline you've got to think
about what's important and what's not
important
and if you're disa if you generally or
often times people that are hyper
disciplined
about little things a lot of times
they're missing
their discipline in other areas of their
life and one of them
and and you we've talked about this
before too which is
somebody that just because someone is
hyper disciplined in their physical
fitness doesn't mean that they're
disciplined in their
rest of their life in many other ways
whether it's financial
whether it's their relationships
whatever like everything they can be
screwing
every they're super disciplined in
weighing their food and doing macro
calorie counting and all that stuff
right
and yet they haven't paid their phone
bill
or whatever and they've got financial
issues or they've got
health like other health issues
and so you need to you need to back off
enough on the little things that don't
matter
that so that the things that matter you
can actually take care of
i had the opportunity to go to fight to
flight school
but instead tested positive on a drug
test
and i was given a general discharge i of
course take full responsibility and feel
like an idiot
how would you recommend moving past this
failure
well if my seal career had ended with a
mistake i would have
figured out what my next mission was
going to be
that's that's what i would have done i
mean i
would have said okay i like that job i
failed at it
what can i learn from that and what can
i do
next differently to make sure i don't
make that mistake again
i'm going to learn from the past but i'm
not going to dwell on it
there's no point in dwelling on it the
only point in dwelling on it is to learn
from it
so that's what i would do here and then
i would take what i
learned from my experiences of where i
failed and i would also take the
positive things that i learned because
you
even that even that failure is a
positive even that failure is a positive
because you realize
you realize the value of the opportunity
that you had and you blew it and you're
like okay i'm never gonna let that
happen again lesson learned
i'm actually stoked i get to learn that
lesson because there's gonna be more
opportunities that come
up in life and you gotta make sure that
you don't
disregard those opportunities when they
come up
and i so i would have taken those
lessons learned take that take that
failure
and turn it into something positive and
made good things happen when i figured
out what my new
mission and new career was going to be
when you you've crushed your daily to-do
list do you then take the time to relax
or do you attack the next day's list
is that against prioritize and execute
since the mission
is done for the day you know just do
more just keep going
even if it's on the next day keep going
do more if you have extra time do
whatever you can do to stay ahead and i
do that
pretty much until i'm brain dead and i i
work i can definitely work myself into
until i'm brain dead like i can get to a
point where i'm reading or i'm writing
and it's just it's just
it's just done i'm done and so i just
have to stop
and take a break and then i'll go do
something mindless for a while
you know so yeah if you've got stuff to
do keep hammering
until you can't hammer anymore and then
say okay you know what
i need a little breather and then take a
little breather and then get back to it
a soldier should always question their
leaders not just their leaders values
but their leader's plans
their leader strategies their leader's
vision you should question everything
that your leader is telling you
and if you see something is wrong then
you should raise your hand and call it
out
and i would say not only is it something
that you should do it's actually your
duty
it's actually your duty is to raise your
hand
as a soldier and i'll tell you this
doesn't only apply
to the military it applies to any
organization
and it might sound like i'm encouraging
um mutiny or rebellion but
actually the opposite is true if you
have a team
that questions the leader the leader
doesn't become weaker
the leader becomes stronger if he's a
good leader if he's on the right path if
he's doing the right thing he becomes
stronger because everyone starts to
understand
why things are happening they understand
the vision more fully
if the leader doesn't have a good vision
and he's getting questioned and he can't
answer the questions yeah he might have
a mutiny on his hands
but it's not because the people are
asking questions because he doesn't know
what he's doing
what lesson do you wish you'd have
learned earlier in life
that you now know
it is discipline equals freedom i mean
that is the thing that that
when i connected that together in my
head
that the fact that that applies to
absolutely everything
that's the biggest lesson that i wish i
would have learned earlier in life
and if i would have figured that out
then
i would have been doing a lot better and
i would have done a lot better it would
have been a lot better of a person
and this is something that i completely
missed as a kid the actions that you
take now
affect your future that sounds so
obvious
but when you're 14 you just think
no nothing i you know my life is only
another 20 minutes
so what i'm doing right now doesn't
really matter so when i
talk to kids i try and explain to them
that discipline equals freedom and then
i try to explain to them
that what you're doing right now really
will
have an impact to where you are in the
future and i don't know if you listen to
that
podcast that i do the warrior kid
podcast that i did number 19
about my friend jeff and
i talked about it on the adult podcast
as well but you know it's a classic
story i had a
best friend when i was little and we
separated
friendship not we were still friends but
we we drifted apart
he started getting into partying getting
into drugs and all that and i didn't
and his trajectory in life just went
down
and i joined the navy which was great
and it put me on a good path
almost involuntarily but
he ended up he ended up killing himself
and
you know it was drugs it was alcohol and
it was just bad
but while i was going through buds he
killed himself and what i tried to
explain to the kids
on the warrior kid podcast it's like the
decisions that the little decisions that
you make
they matter they add up if you want to
learn to deal with stress put yourself
in stressful situations that are under
some kind of control
you know even something like uh
paintball you know we do
gigs in echelon front where we put
people through what we call ftx's
where you go out and you're gonna fire
we usually use
airsoft because it's a little bit more
it's a little easier to work with
but actually what we started using now
is we've got these high-end
laser tag guns and so that's that's what
we use
and they are super effective they're
they're they're awesome they're awesome
training tools
like if we would have had them if we
would have if they would have existed
when i was in the seal teams i would
have used them then because they're that
good
so we use those and we put people in
stressful
situations go hit this target there's
bad guys you know people are going to
get shot there's
people yelling put yourself in stressful
situations and learn to detach
put yourself in stressful situations
with the purpose of learning to detach
and stepping back
mentally to figure out what's going on i
struggle with the daily grind
trading days for dollars but you helped
me make it happen
yeah and my comment was like okay well
thank you i guess
because i hope at the same time that
you're grinding
that you're trading that you're
i hope that you're not trading days for
dollars
long term because long term that's a
losing proposition right
if you're grinding and it's not
doing something you want to do if it's a
grind that you can't
embrace then you got to find a way out
of that right
you got to find you can't trade you
don't want to trade days for dollars
because dollars don't mean anything
day's all you got
so you gotta find a way out
now this does not mean you need to be
rash about it
this doesn't mean tomorrow you walk in
i'm not doing this job anymore i'm
out and now you're broke no don't
be rash and don't throw the baby out
with the bathwater but
do come up with a long-term plan about
what you want to do how you want to do
it where you want to do it
and this might take one year or two
years or
five years it might take five years to
get to where you want to be
that's okay that's fine it's actually
kind of cool when you're grinding right
now because you know there's something
that you're working towards in the long
run that's actually awesome
so but but you got to have an exit
strategy
you got to have an exit strategy you got
to plan and figure out how much money
it's going to take and what are you
going to do you're going to work two
jobs i'm going to
save all my money right now i'm going to
invest here i'm going to pay off my
mortgage whatever it is you're gonna do
so that you can get yourself in a
position where you actually enjoy doing
what you're doing
how important is
purpose reason or cause in being
successful
clearly purpose and reason and cause are
extremely important this is this is the
why
of of your actions this is knowing why
you're doing what you're doing this is
the commander's intent
and so you you absolutely absolutely
these are important
if you don't know why you're doing
something well then let me ask you a
question
why are you doing something it does it's
it's very clear it's very simple to
understand
so yeah you got to know if you don't
know why you're doing something then
what what are you going to do when you
hit an obstacle you're going to stop
what do you what
what adaptations are you going to make
when things go wrong to overcome them
you're not going to make any because you
don't know why you're doing it
yeah so if you have no reason if you
have no reason for doing something
you're not going to do it
so you got to have a long-term goal
you got to understand the underlying
purpose of what you're doing
do you know who you have control over
you you have control you don't have
control over your nine-year-old kid you
might
think you do but you don't you gotta
make you have control over your wife
to just make her you know get in the
game
oh you wanna you wanna stay on the
program you wanna
cook uh uh whatever 14
chicken breasts on a sunday night so you
got two a day during the week
honey make it happen no honey don't make
that happen
if you are a good leader and you explain
what your goals are and you get her on
board with the program
then yeah guess what she's doing on
sunday night helping you cook some
chicken breasts for the week
yeah but this is just like anything else
man
this is just like any other leadership
situation you want to blame the team
when something's going wrong
that's not going to get you a solution
you need to take ownership of the
problem
you need to get the problem solved and
when i say get the problem solved
you this doesn't mean impose your will
on the team that means you need to lead
the team
and there's a big difference don't put a
hundred percent
of your effort into one area because
eventually it will take
you you won't have anything else and by
the way
if you put all your you know if you put
all your
all your eggs in the basket of
intellectual power now you're unhealthy
and you die
right that doesn't you know i don't care
how smart you are you can't do
two plus two when you're dead yeah
so don't put all your focus 100
into one area don't become unbalanced
in your disciplines spread it around and
hold the line
what's the best approach to managing
people
that outperform you yeah i think this is
a simple question as well
what you do in this situation is you
give them all the support you can and
let them run
i'm happy if someone's out before me
that's great you know what else i'll do
try and learn from them
see what they're doing try and spread
the word if i'm in a leadership position
and someone's doing
outperforming everyone great how can we
take that how can we teach it to
everyone else
how can i give them support so they can
run even faster this is no factor to me
i love it
you should be surrounding the more
people you can bring on your team that
outperform you the better you're going
to do
when i retired from the navy and got out
and started the consulting business
working and one of my risk-averse
friends
that was staying in the military
for its its welfare program
right so it's a paycheck right and he
the guy wasn't you know he wasn't all
fired up anymore but he was in and so he
had a mortgage to pay and kids to feed
so he's just staying in
and he kind of looked at me when i was
getting out and i said yeah man i got
bills to pay too but i'm gonna go and
get after it somehow and he said what
are you gonna do
if it you know if the business doesn't
work and you end up you know you're
gonna come back in and about what are
you gonna do you won't be able to get
back in blah blah blah
and i said bro worst case scenario
everything goes to hell guess what i'm
gonna be doing i have an rv
i will be in my rv with my family we'll
be driving up and down the coast of
california
raiding jiu jitsu schools and training
and i'll be surfing and it's all good
and it won't cost me barely anything to
do that my retirement cover will be good
to go that attitude for me freed me
like oh worst case scenario i lose
everything cool i still have my rv it's
paid for
yeah yeah we're good one of my
direct subordinates one of my guys that
worked for me he would he would call me
up or
pull me aside with some major problems
some issue that was going on
and he'd say awesome we got this and
that the other thing and i look at him
and i'd say
good and finally one day he was
telling me about some issue that he was
having some problem and
he said i already know what you're gonna
say i said well what am i going to say
he said you're going to say good
he said that's what you always say when
something is wrong
and going bad you always just look at me
and say good
and i said well yeah when
things are going bad there's gonna be
some good
that's gonna come from it didn't get the
new high-speed gear we wanted
good didn't get promoted
good more time to get better
oh mission got canceled good we can
focus on another one
didn't get funded didn't get the job you
wanted
got injured sprained my ankle got tapped
out
good got beat
[Applause]
unexpected problems good
we have the opportunity to figure out a
solution
[Applause]
that's it when things are going bad
don't get all bummed out don't get
startled don't get frustrated
if you can say the word good
guess what it means you're still alive
it means you're still breathing and if
you're still
well breathing you still got some fight
left in you
so get up dust off
reload recalibrate
[Music]
[Applause]
re-engage
and go out on the attack i always say
that discipline is the root of all
good qualities
but you have to absolutely apply it
to things outside of just waking up
early
it's it's everything it's working out
every day making yourself stronger and
faster
and more flexible and healthier
discipline is eating the right foods to
fuel your system
it it's about disciplining your emotions
so you can make good decisions it's
about having
the discipline to control your ego
so your ego doesn't get out of hand and
control you
it's about treating people the way you
would want to be treated
and and doing the tasks that you don't
necessarily
want to do but that you know will help
you
or help your team
it's about facing your
fears takes discipline to face your
fears
so you can conquer them
and that's what discipline is discipline
means taking the hard road
the uphill road to do what's right
for yourself and for other
people
it's so often the easy path
the easy path it calls to us to be weak
for that moment to break down for that
moment
to give in to the desire and the
short-term gratification
but the discipline will not allow that
the discipline calls for strength
and fortitude and will
it won't accept weakness it won't
tolerate
another breakdown
the discipline can seem
like it's your worst enemy
but the reality is
discipline is your best friend it will
take care of you like
nothing else can and it'll put you
on that path
the path to strength and health and
intelligence and happiness
[Music]
and most importantly
it'll put you on that path
to freedom people want to know how to
stop the laziness and they want to know
how to stop
the procrastination and you know
they have some idea in their head you
know some
kind of uh a vision
of what they want to do
but they don't know where to start they
don't know where to start it you know
they don't know where to start
and say they say hey where do i start
and
and when's the best time to start and i
have a very simple answer for that
here and now
that's it you you want to improve
you want to get better you want to get
on a
workout program or a clean diet you want
to start a business
you want to write a book or make a movie
or build a house
or a computer or put together some
mobile application
where do you start
you start right here and when do you
start you start right now
you initiate the action aggressively you
go
because the idea isn't going to execute
itself
and and the book isn't going to write
itself and the weights
out in the gym they're not going to move
themselves
you have to do it and you have to do it
now
and that means you got to stop thinking
about it
and stop dreaming about it and stop
researching every aspect of it
and reading all about it and debating
the pros and cons of it
just start doing it
take that first step
and make it happen
get after it and get after it here
and now there's been thousands and
hundreds of thousands and millions of
warriors
that have been in very
stressful situations and faced evil and
faced
death much worse than the situation
i'm in or urine that we might consider
stressful and i even did this when i was
overseas when i was on deployment when i
was a combat leader
i was feeling stress and you know what
we took casualties and it was
awful and it was heartbreaking and
but there were other soldiers and
warriors throughout time that have been
in much worse situations
gettysburg or vicksburg or the battle of
the bulge
and and all those
horrible situations
they prove really that humans can
withstand
almost almost unimaginable stress
which meant to me that i could too
and you can
and the first step for me is doing that
taking that
look to gain some perspective
and then in order to gain perspective
you got to do something that we already
talked about you've got to detach
you've got to detach from the problems
or the stress that you're experiencing
so that you can get that perspective of
them
now
there's a couple different types of
stress now if it's
something that you can control that's
causing you stress
well why aren't you getting control of
it now there's also stress that's caused
by things that you cannot control
and if you remember talking earlier
about artillery and how
horrible that was and what made it so
horrible was that there's no control
over
so if you can't control something
and you can't get control of it
you have to at least
embrace what you can and i'm not saying
you're going to embrace
artillery shelling but i'll tell you
what when it comes to things
like artillery or for us in ramadi was
ieds and we could do everything we could
do to mitigate that risk
but eventually there's only so much you
can do and you cannot completely
eliminate it
but you can't control it so why are you
going to worry about it
why are you going to stress about it
if there's something that's completely
beyond your control
you cannot you've got to detach from it
and not let yourself get stressed about
it
and on top of that
if it's something that you can't control
how can you look at it in a different
light how can you
see it in a way that you could actually
take advantage of it
how can you take
that stress and make it into some kind
of ally
you know the the chaos of combat
is something that i couldn't control but
i had to embrace it so i could try and
figure out how to take advantage of it
so when it comes to stress
don't fight it
turn it on itself and use it
use it use it to make yourself sharper
and more alert
and use it to make yourself think more
and learn more and get better
and use that stress
as a catalyst to make yourself better
your book isn't i mean it's thick but
i should have been able to read this in
two or three solid days of reading yes
i told you how successful i was yes not
very
and that bugs the sh at him
and it's a it's a it's a
uh it's a fail it's a it's a
you know what though i think this is a
failure on my part i i
i think that this is the same thing that
we were talking about on the last
podcast
and i think echo said
when you say oh you know what i'm not
going to finish this book right now it's
it i don't really want to it's sort of
like when you say oh i'm not gonna
quit no it's not that i don't want to
though that's what i'm saying you say
but i don't want to do it right now i
can push it off a little bit
you accept that you accept that answer
you accept that answer the soldier
jody right wouldn't accept that answer
would not do you self-talk not really
not really i'm not a guy that says you
know i'm gonna do this i'm gonna do that
i just do it
you know i actually took this question
from twitter and i answered the question
in
one word
you've lived a life dominated by doubt
and fear
how do you step into bravery
step
that's how you step into bravery step
take
the step step
aggressively towards your fear
and that that step towards your fear
is the step into bravery
because we're we're scared of what we
don't know
and there is only one way
to learn and to know and that is to
confront
that fear you have to step you have to
go
and this simple action this
simple attitude
it answers so many questions
if you're afraid of
fighting and altercations go train
jiu-jitsu if you're afraid of heights
work on some rock climbing
climbing if you're afraid of the water
it's time to swim it's time to surf it's
time to get out there
if you're afraid of pull-ups if if
you're afraid of pulps do pull ups if
you're in squats do squats
if you're afraid of public speaking go
speak in public
if you're afraid to start a business
start a business
make it small and on all these what you
have to do is you have to mitigate the
risk and you have to ease yourself into
it
but you got to go for it and eventually
you will overcome
that fear but the hard part is
you got to take that first step yeah you
got to take that first step
to begin to inoculate yourself against
the fear against the fear of the thing
that's in your mind because that fear
generally is in your mind yeah that you
know
when you get up on stage to do public
speaking
people are not going to throw tomatoes
at you and say oh my you're an
idiot to get off the stage no they're
they're going to sit there
you know so there's nothing to fear
i tweeted at jocko and i asked him uh if
you'd like to take part in a fitness
challenge
he graciously came with a counter offer
and said
how about a grappling match for some
reason
i said yes and so here i am now
and accept your faith
oh
okay okay
he actually asked to get choked out so
there it is
jiu-jitsu
[Applause]
fairly decisive uh but yeah you know
really honestly it's just uh
because i've been training for a long
time and i have that skill set you know
it's something that anybody could get
it's not because i'm special it's just
because i trained for a long time doing
this
and if the roles were reversed and he'd
been training longer than me
you'd be doing that right there to me
that's the way it works even if i look
like this and you look like that
yeah i'm more than happy to get 135
pounder in here right now that'll show
me what it's about
they'll do you worse than i just did you
i'll hear you if you want that i do not
i got guys standing by that are hungry
i've had enough
of jocko for rome wasn't built in the
day
we all know that everyone hears that
but rome also didn't fall apart
overnight either
it took hundreds of years for rome
to reach its peak but it also took time
hundreds of years for
rome to decay and fall apart
and that is representative
of life because you don't achieve
worthwhile goals quickly or
easily they take time
they take struggle they take
relentless pursuit day in
and day out that's what it takes
but also things don't usually
fall apart quickly either
at least at first it it's it's a slow
process a little slip here
a little set back over there a little
wearing down of discipline
and will over time
that's the thing success and failure
are generally slow processes
either slowly building things up
or gradually tearing them down
and that's why i say you've got to pay
attention
you have to watch you have to watch
every single second
because those seconds
they turn into minutes and minutes
turn into hours and hours turn into days
and days turn in to years
and so that second
that second that just went by
that counted
and so did that second and so did that
one
and in those precious seconds
you were either building
or you were decaying you were either
gaining ground
or you were losing ground
in that second
and in every second
every second counts
so make
every second
count and when a team takes ownership
of its problems the problems get solved
and that is true on the battlefield
it is true in business and it is true in
life
so i say
take ownership take extreme ownership
don't make excuses don't blame any other
person
or any other thing
get control of your ego
don't hide your delicate pride
from the truth
take ownership of everything in your
world
the good and the bad
take ownership of your mistakes take
ownership of your shortfalls
take ownership of your problems and then
take ownership
of the solutions that will get those
problems
solved
take ownership of your mission
take ownership of your job of your team
of your future and take ownership of
your
life
and lead
lead
lead yourself and your
team and the people in your life
lead them all
to victory tactics to flank slash
shift a ferocious analyzer from
paralysis
to go meaning uh what someone who
overthinks
things hesitates to planning and
planning and planning and planning well
there's a couple things here
if the person is above you or below you
in the chain of command
so if they're below you in the chain of
command you you know you explain to them
you say look we don't need perfection
we're not going to have a 100 solution
we don't have 100 of the information
that's a good enough solution we need to
move forward let's execute um
and you know what i'll take if things go
wrong don't worry about it i'll take
responsibility for it i'm not going to
blame you which is what you're going to
do anyways
as a good leader so that's what you're
going to do if you're there below you in
the chain of command
[Music]
if they're above you in the chain of
command guess what
same thing you're going to tell the same
thing like hey boss we don't need
perfection here
look boss we're not going to get all the
information we need we're not going to
get 100 solution we got a 90
solution and let's go for it
and if things do go wrong you can blame
me i don't care
so boom the whether they're above you or
you know below you the chain of command
you might change your tact or your
verbage a little bit but it's the same
same overall concept you got to get them
to understand that we don't need
perfection we need to move forward
and the other thing is you explain the
cost of not moving
the cost of staying still the cost of
being reactive instead of proactive
and basically the cost of not being
aggressive because that's what we're
talking about is a lack of aggression
and so what does that look like will you
explain to them that the longer we
sit the better position the enemy gets
into
the longer we wait the less
we know about what is actually happening
think about that one the more you sit
here and you're planning the less we
know what's going on out there the
things are happening
they're changing they're evolving the
enemy's maneuvering
there's developments on the battlefield
or in the marketplace and you don't even
know because you're sitting in the
planning space
the longer we wait the less time we have
to recover
if something does go wrong so if we sit
here and plan
for 47 days and on the 40th day we step
out and we start to execute something
goes wrong
we're not going to make the 50-day mark
because we spend all that time planning
so the longer that you're sitting around
the last time you have to recover and
adapt and adjust
and the longer that you wait while
you're doing planning
the less relevant your plan actually
becomes
so that's what you need to make people
understand
those days when i'm tired
or worn out or
just basically sick of the grind
what what do i do on those days
i go anyways
i get it done even if i'm just
going through the motions i go
through the motions i don't really
want to work out i work out
i i really don't want to hammer on a
project i
hammer on the project don't really
want to get up and get out of bed
yeah i get up and get out of bed
now these could be
signals that you need some time off
and those signals might be right
they could be correct but
don't take today off not today
wait until tomorrow don't don't give
in to the immediate gratification
that is whispering in your ear
shut that down do not listen to that
little voice
instead go through the motions
lift the weights sprint the hill
work on the project get out of bed
now as an overall rule i do not like
procrastination you need to get
things done
but if you are going to rest
that is one thing that you should
procrastinate on
that's the one thing i want you to put
off until tomorrow and
if when tomorrow comes
you still feel like you need to rest or
you need to take a break
then okay take it
but the chances are you won't
you won't need that rest chances are you
will
realize that the desire to rest was just
weakness
it was just the desire to take the path
of least resistance the downhill path
the easy path
and by simply going through the motions
you overcame that path and you stayed on
the righteous path
the disciplined path you stayed on the
war path
character is not a very complex thing
for me character is
[Music]
you do what's right you do what's right
you do the right thing that's what you
do
and if you do the right thing regardless
of what the consequences are
that that represents character and so
then how do you build character
it's a beautiful thing because it's the
same thing if you want to build
character
you do the right thing you do the right
thing for yourself you do the right
thing for your family you do the right
thing for your
the people that you know you do the
right thing for your community you do
the right thing for your country
that's what you do and now on an
individual level
those things are hard things often right
those are hard things you have to make
the right decisions you have to
live a disciplined life those build
characters those little things
that you do on a daily basis to make
yourself better
to improve your health to improve your
your situation in life you're doing
those things they're hard to do
and when you do those things they build
your character
and ultimately they lead to your your
character being
a good character as opposed to a bad one
a person's strengths
are often their biggest weaknesses
and so that also means that their
weaknesses
can be their strengths
so me
i am weak in all those ways
that i listed i am weak
but i don't accept that i don't accept
that i
am what i am and that that
is what i'm doomed to be no
i don't accept that i'm fighting
i'm always fighting i'm struggling and
i'm scrapping
and i'm kicking and clawing at those
weaknesses
to change them stop them
some days i win
some days i don't but
each and every day i get back up
and i move forward
with my fists clenched toward the battle
toward the struggle
and i fight with everything i've got to
overcome those weaknesses
and those shortfalls and those flaws
as i strive to be just a little bit
better today
than i was yesterday before the war uh
the military sent me to college
so i had to go to college and i as i
said earlier as i've
said before i was super focused when i
went to college i'd been in the sealed
teams for 10 years
i was a go-getter i was a hard charger i
was like oh you want me to read this
book
boom i would sit down and just force
myself to read it
and then got back to the seal teams
and like like when i went to college i
literally read
every single thing that i was assigned
and
nobody does that in college nobody does
that i read
every single page of every single thing
i was assigned during college that's
ridiculous it's almost a waste of time
it's almost embarrassing echo definitely
thinks it's a waste of time
but but it was because i just could just
lock my brain down and get it done so
then get back to the teams and the teams
officer and the teams you have a lot of
administrative practice to do
evaluations and
after actions reports and all these
things and i would do the same thing i
just go into lockdown mode and i put my
brain on it and boom i'd go through it
and just get it done i would just be
able to focus so like each thing
laser focus laser focused that report
done gone
report done there's another kind of
instinct
that you need to be on the lookout for
and this one is a liar
this one is a saboteur
well this one is a backbiter
and like the devil himself he's a
shape-shifter he's gonna disguise
himself
and make you think he's got your best
interest in mind
but he doesn't this is the
instinct that says you've had enough
this is the instinct that says you've
you've given it your best shot
you can you can stand down
you can back off you can take a knee
this is the instinct that says
you can rest now
[Music]
do not listen to that instinct do
not listen that instinct
is a liar and wants to bring you down
that that's the instinct that's a a
defense mechanism
he wants to give you an out a place to
run
to a little little place of sympathy
and amnesty a little place of amnesty
where
everything is forgiven we're all these
these failures can gather together in
comfort and drown their sorrows
in lies and in deception
and they tell each other
and they'll tell you you did the best
you could
no they'll say the deck the deck the
deck was stacked against you
and they'll say it's not your fault
and they'll tell you it's okay to stop
it's okay to settle it's okay
to give up
and that is the instinct you need to
fight you need to push
back to smash into the ground
do not take the easy way out
do not give up based on instinct
if you are forced to stand down
to retreat so that you can rebuild and
re-attack
so be it but make
that decision based on logic
not on the instinct of surrender
and defeat
[Music]
and you need to train
that instinct your instinct
train it to say get up
go fight on
and if that is what you become if that
becomes your fundamental reaction
to adversity if that becomes your gut
instinct
then you will overcome
just about anything that stands in your
path
i know i've said before that knowledge
is the most important thing
but the reality is if you don't have the
strength
or actually the health
to back that up or even to function as a
human being physically
then your knowledge and your mental
strength doesn't really even matter
so that comes into play and being
big and strong is also totally useless
if you're mentally weak and you quit
now being mentally strong should
actually
lead you to being physically strong
because if you are mentally strong
then you can work and train to become
physically strong
but if you're mentally weak
then you will not hold the line on the
good
foods and the good workouts and you
won't
get physically strong or healthy
[Music]
so can you be weak and strong at the
same time
yes but i say be
strong train your
physical strength and exercise your
mental strength
by doing the right things the hard
things
the things you know you're supposed to
do
do them and be as strong
as you can mentally physically
and emotionally for yourself
for your team for your family
hold the line
and be strong you know when you're in
the military you have this discipline
and beyond that beyond the discipline
that's imposed on you you also have a
lot that you have to just
hold the line yourself i mean when
you're in the military
sure you go through boot camp where
there's a drill instructor that julian
and all that but
once you're in the military you're doing
what you have to do it's self-discipline
that you learn that and you become
self-disciplined and what happens is
guys get out and that's
that's gone and that hurts them and the
other thing that hurts them
is they don't know what their mission is
anymore
and and my big thing with people that
i've been telling vets now is
find what your next mission is go find
whatever your next mission and i don't
care what it is but it has to be
something
when people are not going anywhere when
they're when they're failing when
they're when they don't have
the drive it's because they're not
accepting responsibility for anything
and and so my way of saying that is like
you need a new mission you need to be
responsible for something
and you need to go and move towards some
new mission
should someone always be detached okay
straightforward question the answer is
no
someone shouldn't always be detached
because otherwise
you aren't enjoying anything
in your life so don't always be attached
detached no
but at the same time that being said
you should be aware all the time
if you are getting sucked into the
emotional vortex
right you've got to be aware of that
once you have that awareness you don't
need to be attached all the time at all
yeah you can i'm not always detached
at all but but i've got
clear warning signs when things start
going sideways
and i start going down some vortex i
know immediately and i just detach
so it's really easy it's but it does
take practice
and eventually you realize that you know
when you're feeling overwhelmed when
you're feeling
emotional and you're feeling angry or
you're feeling frustrated
when you start feeling those things and
you sense them really quickly and you
recognize them
you just detach boom you're done yeah so
that's what you got to do start
recognizing those red flags so that
you can enjoy the good things and when
something starts getting crazy
you can detach yeah so it's like an
overall skill
of being able to control when to detach
and when you don't have to being able to
identify
yeah when you need to detach
then being able to detach then you're
good
as a leader at what point am i allowed
to go
to others and say i need you because i
recognize i'm not capable of pushing
toward
forward on my own or should that be an
instance where i need to take a step
back and apply more discipline to my
life
and find a way to push forward by myself
okay
you are allowed to say that to your team
member
immediately that you need them
absolutely
if you of course you need your team
because if you didn't need your team why
would they be
there yeah if you if you can do
everything yourself then
you don't have a team yeah right you
just do everything yourself
so while you of course should be working
hard you should be applying discipline
as a leader it's your job to actually
lead things
and to let other people support and make
things happen
and there's nothing wrong with that you
and also you don't want to be stuck in
the weeds
doing minute things so
if you're not capable i think what might
be holding this individual back
there's two things number one is i feel
like i should take extreme ownership of
everything
i feel like i should do everything
myself that is not what extreme
ownership is
stream ownership isn't doing everything
yourself and also what can come into
play is
your ego because you don't want to ask
people for help
and that's not a good sign there's
nothing wrong with asking people for
help
if you need it in fact that's the humble
thing to do hey echo i don't know how to
quite finish out this uh you know this
thing up this project i'm working out
can you give me a hand with this
i don't know how to work a video
recorder can you show me how to do that
right
whatever um so so there's no problem
with that you're allowed to ask
you can you can say that immediately in
fact your team should feel that you are
counting on them and relying on them
they should know that and then
put your ego aside ask for help no
problem that doesn't mean you're giving
away
that doesn't mean you're not taking
ownership that doesn't mean you're not
applying discipline
it means you're working as a team
together to accomplish a mission again
if a t if
if a mission is so easy that you can
accomplish it yourself you don't need a
team why do you have them
if you can do it all yourself just by
applying discipline cool you don't need
anyone else
if your but your mission should be
larger than one human being
can accomplish so that's why you have
other people on board to help you out
trying to think of how to
stop the loop of my sacrifices
have been rejected and and the way that
you stop that loop
is instead of saying the sac my
sacrifices were rejected so my hard work
my effort my everything that i'm doing
to try and move forward it's not working
and and if you want to go towards hell
you keep saying well it's it's not
working but it's but it's because of
everyone else
it's they're rejecting me they're not
accepting what i've done
whereas if you say to yourself oh it
didn't work
okay it's my fault what can i do better
and that's how you start moving in the
other direction
we work together as a team and enables
us not only to survive a situation like
that but actually dominate
the first law of combat that we talk
about
is called cover and move which means if
leif and i are going to assault
a target you know over there i'll get in
a good firing position
i'll engage the enemy and keep their
heads down where they can't shoot back
and while i'm doing that leif will get
up and maneuver to a better position
cover and move
essentially is teamwork working together
in full support of the other parts of
the team some of the things that can
make teamwork fall apart
number one those individual elements can
get
fixated target fixation inside their own
world
if i'm here trying to engage the enemy
and all of a sudden i get so focused on
that
that i forget about life and i forget
about what he's doing all of a sudden
i'm no help to him anymore sometimes it
can come with ego
where i want to outperform life even
though we're on the same team
i want to outperform him with my element
maybe i do some things that
actually sabotage him i know that sounds
crazy but it happens it definitely
happens
it happens in the seal team sometimes
and it definitely happens in the
corporate world and we've seen that
you've lived a life dominated by doubt
and fear
how do you step into bravery
step
that's how you step into bravery step
take
the step step
aggressively towards your fear
and that that step towards your fear
is the step into bravery
because we we're scared of what we don't
know
and there is only
one way to learn
and to know and that is to confront that
fear
you have to step you have to go and this
simple action this simple
attitude it
answers so many questions
so many questions
how do you get to the gym every day
you step you go how do you how do you
change your diet
you step you go
how do you overcome fear of failure or
fear of success or
or fear of fear itself
you step
and how do you face the fear of the
unknown you step
don't wait anymore don't think anymore
don't plan anymore don't
contemplate anymore don't make any more
excuses or
justifications don't
rationalize anything else no
no and no
instead be aggressive
take action now and what is the first
action that you need to take
what's the first step you need to take
the first step you need to take
is just that
step you've lived a life dominated by
doubt and fear
how do you step into bravery
step
that's how you step into bravery step
take
the step step
aggressively towards your fear
and that that step towards your fear
is the step into bravery
because we we're we're scared of what we
don't know
and there is only
one way to learn
and to know and that is to confront that
fear you have to step you have to go
and this simple action this
simple attitude
it answers so many questions
so many questions
how do you get to the gym every day
you step you go how do you how do you
change your diet
you step you go
how do you overcome fear of failure or
fear of success or
or fear of fear itself
you step
and how do you face the fear of the
unknown you step
don't wait anymore don't think anymore
don't plan anymore don't contemplate
anymore
don't make any more excuses or
justifications
don't rationalize anything else
no no and no
instead be aggressive
take action now and what is the first
action that you need to take
what's the first step you need to take
the first step you need to take
is just that
step it is not easy to identify the
enemy
in combat in war so what you have to do
is you have to control what you can
control
right you got to be prepared you've got
to train you've got to study
you've got to rehearse you've got to
remain vigilant
you've got to maintain discipline in
everything you do so that when the enemy
does reveal itself
you have the ability to
out think it to out maneuver
to out fight the enemy
and it's actually the same thing in
business
right the enemy can be hard to identify
your competitors
aren't broadcasting their next move
you don't know what the market's going
to do you can't be certain about the
next trend or the next
downturn or the next bubble that's going
to burst you can't know those things
so you have to do the same thing you
have to control what you can
control which is you
gotta gather intelligence you gotta
analyze the metrics that you can track
you gotta train yourself and your team
to be prepared
for both the known and also be prepared
for the unknown
figure out what the likely contingencies
are
and have some plans
to execute if those contingencies occur
maintain discipline as an organization
so that you have the
flexibility and the responsiveness to
maneuver effectively and efficiently
when the unpredictable actually happens
so instead of suffering and falling
apart in the chaos
you can take advantage of it and win
and that's business and life
is the same the enemy is not always
clear
in life it can be hard to tell who's
gonna try and bring you down
or what is going to bring you down
there's distractions
there are things out there that will do
you harm
that are so camouflaged you can't see
them at all
there are deceitful people
there are accidents that can occur and
diseases that take root and there's
bad luck and there's murphy's law and
there's times
when it seems that the whole world
is against you the whole world
[Music]
is the enemy
and the same rules apply
control what you can control
you train hard learn maintain
the unmitigated daily discipline
in all things how do self-awareness
self-assessment and self-improvement
begin and how do they continue over time
try to imagine the way other people
see you and what other people are
thinking of you
and one place where this happens and it
definitely happened to me is when i
started getting put in charge of things
i started thinking about other people's
perspectives
what are they seeing if
you're in charge then what do your
subordinates
see you do what do your subordinates
hear you say
what kind of representation
are they receiving
and if you work for someone else it's
the same questions
what does the boss see me do what does
the boss
hear me say what kind of representation
am i making of myself to my boss
and then you start thinking about what
are your friends
and family think what do they see
what do they hear
and so the question becomes how well do
you
represent yourself what shortfalls
do you have now when you first start
looking it's like you're looking at an
overgrown
lawn there are some big
obvious problems so you do a broad just
kind of
general cut of the grass you fix some of
the big easy problems
that are obvious but once you've done
that
once you've gotten rid of some of those
big obvious problems you notice
some more detailed problems so then you
handle them
and once you've got those handled you
see even smaller and more detailed
issues so you start trying to fix them
and that's what you do with yourself you
continually detach
and then you look and then you refine
and then you detach and then you look
and then you refine and then you detach
and
you look and then you refine that's what
you do
that's how you get better and that
process
doesn't stop it can't stop because if
you
stop refining then
then the weeds grow back and the next
thing you know you can't see yourself
anymore and when you can't see yourself
anymore
when you stop looking at you yourself
then you accept
you accept anything
and that's wrong
don't accept the faults don't give
yourself the benefit of the doubt you've
got to be your
own harshest critic
and hold the line most important here is
it isn't me
it's you and sure you may have grabbed
some
little foothold from the podcast or from
one of the books
but it isn't me that changes you it's
you
you set the small goals you
achieve those goals then set some more
and achieve those and
set some more goals maybe a little bit
bigger but not that much bigger
just start start
small start with changing
tomorrow morning just tomorrow morning
get that squared away
and then move on to the next day and the
next
and move your life to a better place
one little step
one little victory at a time
i'm a veteran of the infantry and when i
took over
a fire team for the first time i made
the mistake of drawing
hard lines in the sand this immediately
alienated members of that team draw a
lot hard lines in the sand
and eventually you realize that they're
either unrealistic or people can't
maintain them
you have set yourself up for failure
what is that exactly like journalism so
no matter what we will not
blah blah blah blah blah blah yeah
there's the line no matter what
we will we will win every single
road march that we do as a fire team in
this while we're while we're here
on this training thing okay well guess
what that's a
that's hard there's other there's some
other fire teams that are also
want to win and and so you've drawn a
hard line to send that's not really a
good example
a good example is like no matter what
we're going to muster every morning at 4
30 in the morning
no matter what and
you know then the guys are out on patrol
until
2 38 in the morning and now the next
morning you're good no matter what i
said no matter what well
it's not good for them it's unrealistic
so you drew a hard line in the sand and
now you got to back it down
so and all you have to do is soften the
statement a little bit hey guys
to the best of our ability if we can
we're going to get here every morning at
4 30 for muster
there's a little there's a little room
to play there right
and that's that's fine so again i i
there's there's not a lot of there's not
a question here but
one of the reasons i think that that i
that i wanted to talk about it was
because i think people
look at me yeah and even hear me
on a peripheral level and they think oh
i bet chocolate just laid down the hard
lines
it's it's my way or the highway right
yeah
and and the the the opposite
is actually true and the reason that
i came to that conclusion
was because i worked for leaders like
that and i hated
working for leaders like that so i
tried to never be a leader like that i
can't
[Music]
this is an expression that is vilified
in our minds beginning at a young age
every time a young child announces this
decision they are corrected
the first adult that hears it asks them
whether or not they have even tried
generally this confrontation will result
in the child giving their task
another attempt until their attention
span moves on to something else
the adult will see this and chuckle
themselves with knowledge
that this is just a child who has yet to
learn the art of
art and virtue of perseverance by the
time this child comes of age however
they will have been told by adults more
times than they could count
that there is no such thing as can't
it is interesting then to think about
how many adults seem to proclaim this
expression in their lives
it is because is it because like many
things
that adults tell children they are
simply telling the child a general rule
that the child must follow
but can be broken once one is grown
or is it because these adults are simply
repeating what they were told as
children
without thoroughly examining what the
phrase i
can't truly suggests
if you confronted an adult that claims
they can't do something with the same
question about whether or not they have
tried the answer will almost always be
yes
adults have learned enough to know that
is unreasonable to say
they can't until they have at least
tried once therefore
the real question that we should be
asking in response is
have you tried everything
have you exhausted every possible option
scenario
combination tool and approach
i do not simply refer to the ones that
you knew of at the time you decided to
undertake your task
i mean have you re also researched
possibilities that you had known about
have you determined whether or not there
is another person
out there that has performed the exact
same task you are attempting or at least
something similar
have you exhausted this research have
you read every book
blog journal magazine bathroom stall
and website if the answer to any of
these questions is no
then go back and try again because if
you don't because you don't truly know
if you can do something
until you've tried absolutely everything
the fact of the matter is that rarely if
ever
is the answer to all these questions yes
therefore what is it that people
actually mean when they say
i can't a more accurate
but more verbose way of saying it would
be
i don't care about or want
enough this task or the resultant
benefits of
it in order to do all that is necessary
to achieve it
i was told countless numbers of times by
people during my month of marathons
that they couldn't run one marathon let
alone 31 straight
every now and then when i had time i
would discuss what they'd said
we would jointly conclude that if
something they cared about
and depended on them doing so it would
be possible
the most common example i used was if
someone had a gun to your child's head
do you think you could do it then
therefore the phrase i can't denotes a
lack of investment as opposed to a lack
of potential
or ability i do not mean to say that
every person i had this conversation
with
should have had the motivation to run
marathons it was something that i
decided to do
not them i merely wanted to express
to them what i'm expressing here given
the right purpose
and enough time you can
everyone that's out there grinding
working driving trucks
pouring concrete hammering on a project
building bridges or building software
sowing some
garments or sowing a field
farmers factory workers
engineers electricians plumbers and
pilots and ground crew and cooks
and waitresses to everyone out there
working hard
and listening to this and just trying to
get yourself a little bit better
today than you were yesterday
thanks for listening and
as you meet struggles
and as you struggle to stay on the path
first of all
remember you don't have to fight alone
reach out to your comrades
in arms
call for fire support when you need it
we win wars because we stick together
and when we stick together
we can overcome any enemy
and the struggles that you face
when they when they do try to flank you
do what jody did do what a soldier
does turn into the ambush
turn toward the enemy fire
and attack i think if you took out the
trash sometime
you're the boss but you see that the
trash is getting overfilled and you just
grab it and take it out
maybe in your mind you think you'd be
losing respect but you actually wouldn't
be
at all in fact everyone looks even goes
oh he's a good guy
and you're working hard and you still
gotta maintain the discipline
the more that you treat them with
respect the more they're gonna respect
you
they're gonna know that you're not too
high and mighty
they're gonna know that you're down to
earth when i was a platoon commander
task commander i picked up brass
i cleaned the ranges with the boys i
would recommend
that kind of attitude it didn't make
people think oh jocko's doesn't have
anything better to do they actually knew
i had stuff to do
but what i got to do pick up brass with
the boys build the relationships
set the example they're going to respect
you for it is it ever okay to violate
core
values to achieve a goal
okay so first of all really obvious
your values and your goals should be
aligned
they should not be adversarial they
shouldn't be countered to each other
and if you think about what your goals
are your goals should be set up in a way
that they support your values
and vice versa that's just the way it is
so i'm not sure where
this is going to be an issue if you're
setting up goals that are contrary to
your values you got some
issues now i guess if you had the goal
of winning the
blue belt jiu jitsu championships
and in order to win you you cheated like
you
claimed someone was reaping your leg and
you said oh you tap and you get the guy
to qualify and you win
that could be an example right yeah now
do i support that no
you know that's wrong you you going
against the values of
actually the values of martial arts to
do that so you didn't win anything you
didn't achieve your goal because you
weren't actually the best
so i say no on that one uh another one
let's say you wanted to make a certain
level of profit
at your company so you cheated a little
bit on the quality of the manufacturing
and you sold items that weren't quite
reliable
do i support that no right for and well
and why
let me tell you why because your goal
your goal is not even aligned with your
goal itself because when you start
making
substandard manufactured items what's
going to happen in the long run
people can say we don't like these we're
not going to buy them anymore
so you didn't win you might have won in
the short term but you didn't win
and again you're going against your
value you should have values that you
don't want to
you know take profit over making good
product
and again in the long run that value is
going to cost you
right people aren't going to want to buy
your product anymore i need a mission
[Music]
we all need a mission
that's what life should be is a mission
that's what gives your life purpose and
focus
and drive and ultimately
satisfaction now
that mission can be the job you work at
it can be providing for your family or
it can be getting better at jiu jitsu or
stronger at olympic lifting or starting
a business that you want to grow and
build and take over the world
and sometimes people ask me what to do
if they don't know what their mission
is or what their mission should be
and i tell them if they're in that
situation
go help someone go help someone else
make that your mission
because that will make you better
and it'll make the world better and
eventually from that you'll see what
your mission is
on social media i see this a lot guys
will hit me up girls will hit me up
uh something went wrong with a client
i stepped in i took ownership they
thanked me
problem solved got it squared away i ca
people are surprised
people are surprised that it works
people are surprised that it works and
again
just to make sure everybody knows that
that alone doesn't work you still have
to prob solve the problem that you
caused with the client right right
you you you gave them what they needed
late or it's going to be late and now
you say it's my fault
that doesn't mean that you don't need to
get it to an asap and make up some
corrective matters and lower the price
to do something so that it makes up for
the problem
but the worst thing you can say is well
you didn't specify exactly what you
wanted in the order and therefore we
couldn't get you what you wanted on time
okay we're never coming back for
business again and we're angry this
whole time and i'm going to short you
money when we pay you in
anyways if i pay you at all the next
time you get into a situation
and you write down you take the excuses
and the reasons
that you come up with look at them
and then figure out how they were how
those things were
actually your fault and or how you could
have prevented them because a lot of
times it's like
here's here's one uh hey boss we didn't
get the mission accomplished
because the weather rolled in and we
couldn't launch on the mission
that's that's the problem now we all
know
that we don't control the weather so
when you so you write the problem down
we failed the mission because we didn't
control the weather
we can't control the weather that's why
we failed the mission that's my excuse
that's a
that's a logical reason there's that's
that's a that's a legitimate excuse
but don't use it what you do is you say
what could i have done
to have controlled the weather okay okay
okay wait
i can't control the weather what could i
have done i could have
come up with a contingency plan i could
have come up we could have
staged in a better place so then you go
to the boss and you say look boss
here's what happened the weather went
south
really bad that was a problem
but it's a problem that i should have
done a better job taking care of
what i should have done was i should
have had a contingency plan
i should have staged closer to the
target area that i could have
taken vehicles instead of helicopters
that's my fault
from now on i will absolutely have a
secondary plan
this won't happen again we can't control
the weather but we can control
how we plan and how we execute and this
won't happen again
there you go so you take the most
outrageous thing that you know you can't
control you figure out a way to control
it
and you take ownership of that thing and
it's gonna
it's gonna make your life so much better
and by the way
the next time you have a mission and you
plan that contingency
and you actually execute and implement
what you said you're gonna do guess what
you will accomplish the mission
there's a whole part of ownership that
preempts the problem
if you've got someone that knows if i
know that i can make an excuse
if i know that i can make an excuse then
guess what i'm not going to set things
up properly
if i don't set things up properly more
often or
more often than the other way i will
fail to
execute what i'm supposed to execute if
you have an excuse right same same thing
with you as an individual human being
if you as an individual human being if
you got some excuses that you can
throw out there that you can say i had
no control over that
then you know what you say okay what are
my contingency plans what could i have
planned differently
let's eliminate those excuses take
ownership of your freaking life
the reason i wake up at 4 30 in the
morning cause no one else is awake yet
so that gives me the opportunity to do
things that
i need to get done kind of selfishly for
myself
and the big one in that category is
working out and it doesn't feel good at
4 30 when you get up
but by the time seven o'clock rolls
around and you've already worked out
you've already gotten some
some work done and you've got some time
to say goodbye to your kids before they
go to school
it's infinitely better than sleeping in
until 6 45
and you get out of bed and now you miss
your kids going to school or or
whatever you you're not prepared for the
day it's it's awful
something i'm sure you hear a lot is 4
30 like this either just
can't fit into my schedule or if i'm
going to be realistic
i'm probably not going to wake up at 4
30 what do you tell people who say that
yeah and there's people that work night
shifts and there's people that
it's unhealthy for them they can't fall
it's like no be healthy get enough sleep
but first of all
wake up at the same time every day and
if you pick that time and you start
waking up at the same time every day
that's very good for you
it doesn't have to be 4 30 it could be 6
30 it could be seven i don't know what
your personal schedule is
but find out a time pick it set it
stick to it and maintain that schedule
and that's going to end up better for
you
i recommend it's earlier i recommend
that you go to bed earlier because what
are you doing at night most of the time
most of the time at night
you're not working on anything super
productive you're just winding down and
watching
stupid youtube videos or surfing the
internet reading click bait stories
right don't do that
instead go to sleep and then wake up
early don't
just listen don't just
listen do
i'm i'm not just talking
so you know i'm not just talking i'm
doing and i don't want you
to just listen put this information
to work
make today count
every day go forward
get aggressive and attack whether it's
on the battlefield or on the beat
or in the factory or on the farm
or on the construction site or on the
website
in the garage or in the firehouse
don't hesitate
step step
forward
and get after it no matter what you face
no matter how bad it is going to be
when there is a challenge
and by a challenge i mean anything in
life any
any challenge anything that you're
facing the only way to
overcome the challenges that you face
is to start walking
take that step every day
no matter what you are facing
get up and start walking
jackal when did you know you wanted to
be a navy seal well specifically
the seal team part of it wasn't until i
figured that out but
when i was a little tiny kid you know
five six
the only thing i could remember was one
to be some kind of commando you knew
that from that point
from from birth basically now was it
because pop's or an uncle or grandpa was
in the military
my grandfather was in the army and he
was retired from the army but
that wasn't really it i just
instinctively
was putting camouflage on my face and
carrying around sticks and carving them
to look like machine guns when i was a
little kid
for no reason so that's just kind of now
are you from a big family do you have
siblings
two sisters two sisters an older one
younger did they also go in the military
or not at all so just you
just me so from five years old you knew
so when you went in high school
everybody's asking you what are you
going to do after high school you knew
you're going in the military yep
now i've got a special bonus clip that i
think you're going to enjoy but before
that it's time for the question of the
day
i want to know what was your single
biggest takeaway
from this video and what is your plan of
action that you're going to execute this
week to make some immediate
momentum happen when you just get
motivated and watch a video
you have a 35 chance of following
through that's what the science says
but when you write down what time what
day what place you're actually going to
execute when you create the plan
you have a 91 chance of following
through
and i want that for you and when you
commit to people publicly
you increase your chances even more of
actually doing it
so i want to know what your single
biggest takeaway from this video was
and your specific plan of action
to actually get the result you're after
let me know put it down in the comments
below
because i want to celebrate you i've
pretty much
broken down my workouts into four
broad spectrums of working out i'm gonna
pull
on one day i'm gonna push on another day
i'm gonna lift
on the next day and i'm going to squat
on the final day the fourth day and i
just rotate those things through
and they're all based fundamentally on
some pretty basic exercises for pull
it's based on pull-ups
doing pull-ups and you all you need to
do pull-ups is a set of rings or a
pull-up bar and you can handle that
workout
the push is based on push-ups and dips
and all the
exercises that are associated with those
types of movements the lifts for me
are lifting things from the ground over
my head
and then finally squat is based on
squatting
and there's all different kinds of
varieties of squats you can do
and i also include in that sprinting and
overhead squats back squats front squats
all those things get incorporated and
when i'm working
a leg day on top of those four on a
regular basis i want to train my
my metabolic conditioning so i want to
do sprinting
and running and get my heart rate up for
very intense
short periods of time and then on top of
that i do gut exercises which is what we
called
in the seal teams when you're working
your core
is the trendy term to call it or
sometimes you hear it referred to as
abs but i don't like those terms we call
it gut
get some if you want to change your life
in the next 30 days for free
check out my training right here below
or if you want some awesome david
goggins motivation check out the video
right there next to me i think you'll
enjoy them
continue to believe and i'll see you
there